[Musique]
cédric au bon soin enfin nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je m'appelle cédric augé
37 enfin 37 ans la semaine prochaine
ses deux enfants
du secrétaire d'état au numérique fut né
à lyon fut le père coréen de mère
française
bon vous avez une quand même une
expérience en politique un peu vous avez
fait quoi avant de me faire secrétaire
d'état ourdi ministres ou secrétaires
d'état je suis secrétaire d'état le
servir ministre non en fait c'est sous
ministre
lorsque j'ai fait avant j'ai un parcours
un peu
inhabituel dans la politique donc moi je
suis je suis de lyon j'ai toujours
habité à villeurbanne en fait jusqu'à ce
que je fasse une vraie pas avec
j'intègre hec je suis sorti de la
chaussée en 2006 l époque je savais pas
quoi faire je voulais pas faire comme
tous mes amis je trouve que un de mes
amis qui étaient avec moi je sexuelle
cenesex guérini qui fait lui aussi un
parcours depuis
connaissez des gens qui travaillent avec
dominique strauss kahn donc je suis
arrivé dans la campagne dominique
strauss kahn en 2006 et à l'époque on
était les petites mains les petites
mains au fond du couloir dire qu'aux
petites montées en place sur les chaises
je faisais les interviews comme vous
pour les mettre sur le site voit la
honte et ça c'est vraiment les petits
des petites z au fond du couloir et il
trouve que à l'époque parce que c'est
important pour la suite donc dans les
petites mains au fond du couloir il y
avait cette année classe guérini moi
même sommes à l aimer lien majeur malgré
vos et mathias et qu'elle est donc ça on
a fait la campagne des primaires contre
ségolène royal on a perdu comme chacun
sait à ce moment là j'ai pas voulu
rester en politique donc je suis parti
dans une petite agence de com qui
faisait de la com pour les partis
politiques mais aussi pour un certain
nombre s'appelait comment opérationnel
qui s'es une agence de com et conseils
en com qui ensuite est
fa qui travaillait pour les
collectivités territoriales et pour la
politique puis suis resté trois ans met
un sévère 2 combien alors en entrant
1800 euros nets par mois
et en sortant plus que ça je devais être
autour de 2500 entre 2500 et 3000
quelques phrases comme ça
et donc ensuite comme j'avais gardé des
contacts dans le monde politique
gts proche de pierre moscovici et donc
dans la perspective de retour du retour
de dsk je suis venu travailler avec
pierre moscovici en juillet 2010 donc
j'y suis resté de janvier 2007 à juin
2010 dans ma pme
j'ai été un proche collaborateur de
pierre moscovici d'abord quand il était
député ensuite il est devenu directeur
de campagne de françois hollande donc
j'étais son bras droit quand il était
directeur de campagne je les ai suivis
quand il était au ministère des finances
d'abord sur des fonctions politiques et
ensuite parce que profondément
je voulais je voulais retourner dans le
privé sur des fonctions techniques dont
je me suis occupé de restructurations de
thales non je me suis occupé de
restructuration au sein du ministère de
l'économie des finances et ensuite je
voulais aller dans l'industrie et donc
je suis allé voir un certain nombre de
grandes boîtes et j'ai fini par rentrer
chez safran donc où je suis entré en
2014 en septembre 2014 je suis lâché ses
safrans de septembre 2014 à mettre 2017
et en fait c'est là que l'histoire sera
boucle c'est que dans la petite équipe
qui a créé en marche
et qui était auprès d'emmanuel mâcon dès
le début il y avait ici mais les miens
c'est un plaisir et non en fait ça par
disney et venir et donc j'ai un thé et
j'ai été un des fondateurs dans marche à
partir de la rentrée 2015 et donc
ensuite on gagne en mai 2010 est comme
chacun sait
jeu est là le président propose de
devenir conseiller à l'élysée donc j'ai
été conseiller à l'elysée de pendant
deux ans de mettre 2017 à mars 2019 et
depuis mars depuis le 31 mars 2010neuf
je suis secrétaire d'état au numérique
bon on reviendra capture ce passage plus
tard aujourd'hui on va parler guerre
économique qui on a parlé numérique y on
va parler gafa on va parler surveillance
de masse ont déjà les contrôles de
reconnaissance faciale suis désolé le
chargeur qui m'ont tablette comme vous
le voyez c'est artisanal on
va parler tous ces sujets merci d'être
venus est-ce que vous êtes prêts ça
risque de la supra ça risque de taper
fort déjà joie les questions débarquer
sa pique sévère pour justement parce que
je regardais ses interviews et donc je
faire une déclaration liminaire
par essence pour une partie de votre
communauté pour une partie des français
d'ailleurs pas essence parce que je suis
ministre il faut donc le truc parce
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai des techniciens qui
ont pas voulu venir bosser exact que
vous étiez nettement et c'est très
intéressant donc par essence parce que
je suis ministre emmanuel macron parce
que j'ai accompagné me le prends parce
que j'ai fait partie des créateurs de
marche je suis pour une partie de votre
communauté et pour une partie des
français
je sais pas quoi dire un traître un
vendu au grand capital invendus à une
certaine caste jeu l'acceptent c'est en
acceptant d'être ministre on accepte ce
genre de sauge mais ce que je trouve
très grave dans le débat français c'est
que on n'écoute pas ce que les gens ont
à dire on juge de ce qu'ils sont bon moi
je ne ne suis pas je n'y a pas d'une
caste privilégiée si vous voulez on
reviendra sur mon enfant sur l'histoire
de ma famille je n'ose pas le sujet mais
je vais à temps on a le temps on peut
tout abordé je viens de villeurbanne
j'ai fait les jets par la départ l'école
la méritocratie j'ai fait une grande
école j'ai intégré ce qu'on peut appeler
l'establishment et j'ai fait ma voix et
je suis aujourd'hui ministre est-ce que
je pense qu'il est important c'est que
les gens débattent du fonds donc au delà
de ce que les gens sont ce qu on puisse
débattre du fond je le dis parce que
trop souvent je pense et c'est le cas
particulièrement en ligne en fait
les gens ne sont pas n'écoute pas ce que
dit la personne est juge de ce qu'il est
donc aucun problème si les gens mais au
moins qu'on puisse débattre du fond
c'est vraiment le sujet donc je vais
dire des choses j'ai évidemment mes
billets personnel mais bien politique
mais je pense que ce qui est important
c'est qu'on a je fais répondre le plus
honnêtement du monde plus aisément
possible aux questions qui sont posées
mais voilà je pense que c'est vraiment
très important parce que ce que vous
dites c'est important qu'ils aient des
gens qui aient refusé de venir faire
cette interview parce que je suis
ministre emmanuel macron je trouve c'est
très grave chose c'est très grave c'est
à dire tu veux remercier les deux qui ça
je remercie les données dernier moment
parce que quelque part on peut être en
désaccord on peut être en désaccord
violemment c'est à dire penser que ce
que pour ce lot est un énorme problème
et à partir du moment où on n'accepte
pas de discuter et on ferme la porte je
pense que c'est un gros problème pour la
démocratie alors c'est juste ma
déclaration est vrai ça tombe bien on va
pouvoir commencer l'interview
parlons parlons guerre économique vous
revenez des états unis
quand on voit donald trump quand on voit
les gars fin quand on voit le scandale
avec la veille le fait qu'ils soient
faits cliqué d'android quand on voit
tout ça est ce que la france
n'est pas en laisse technologiquement
parlant face aux états unis et face aux
gars fin
alors la réponse est en partie
je pense que d'abord si on veut être
dans la masse critique suffisante pour
être au niveau de la compétition avec
les américains et les chinois je pense
que la question qui va se poser la
question européenne
je prends un exemple quand on est arrivé
aux responsabilités sur l'intelligence
artificielle met en avant n'a fait on
j'ai regardé les chiffres sur
l'intelligence artificielle les l'argent
investit chaque année par les états unis
en fait les atémis et les cafards grosso
modo c'est 40 milliards d'euros par la
chine ces 40 milliards d'euros c'est
moitié les privés moitié publique par
l'europe tout mouillé c'est 5 milliards
d'euros sans même subir peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui c'était trop chiffres de
2007 est aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus
que ça et donc sur une technologie aussi
critique que l'intelligence artificielle
qui va irriguer l'ensemble des secteurs
nous ne sommes pas au niveau
d'investissement en termes d'europe au
niveau de l'europe qui doit nous
permettre de garder d'être compétitif
c'est pas qu'une question technologique
derrière l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la compétitivité des entreprises
donc c'est les emplois et donc c'est la
souveraineté est donc le sujet si votre
question c'est ça dont on tient la route
d'un certain certain nombre de
technologies dans l'est ce dont on peut
se rend compte c'est que dans les
dernières évolutions technologiques
depuis 15-20 ans l'europe et la france
ont un train de retard et c'est je pense
un énorme problème on voit un début de
changement dans l'attitude y compris de
la commission européenne mais on est
encore assez en retard et je pense qu'il
c'est un énorme sujet pour l'heure
j'ouvre une parenthèse alors on connaît
déjà le ministère du numérique on l'a on
a rencontré que c'est le maire à
plusieurs reprises on a fait l'interview
où on s'est revu plus tard on connaît
mounir mahjoubi on a fait une interview
est la chose que j'ai remarquée
personnellement c'est que 11 des micros
équipe alors accès le maire était
planquée dans un espèce de tout petits
bureaux blanqui à bercy avec une équipe
qui était restreinte milliards jama
j'oublie son équipe il était tellement
fatigués qu'ils étaient tous grille il
est aigri et on leur a posé et c'était
encore une équipe réduite vous vous avez
une équipe de combien de personnes pour
s'attaquer à ce marché là vous
fonctionnez 1 combien est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous épuisé vos
collaborateurs parce que vous êtes en
sous effectif à ce que l'état français
vous donne les moyens de bosser
correctement alors me dit pas oui on est
aidé par les autres ministères
je suis conseiller mais cycle haussier
pour cet énorme marché là alors ça
marche pas comme ça à l'état c'est à
dire qu'il ya six conseillers dans le
cabinet et ensuite vous avez
l'administration qui travaillent pour
vous une partie de mes forces vives
c'est la direction générale des
entreprises ça doit être pas 200
personnes qui travaillent au jour le
jour mais les plus proches conseillers
c'est à dire ceux qui font l'équipe
autour ces six conseillers
a plus souvent tuellement quelques
stagiaires extérieur mais c'est celle-ci
conseillé et donc après le bruno le
maire qui est mise de l'économie et des
finances s'est fait secouer rsa et les
parents jeune troupe ses onze
conseillers c'est faux ça c'est pas non
plus beaucoup plus et donc on est dans
cette règle là les cabinets comme moi
j'étais au ministère de l'économie des
finances pierre moscovici ça devait être
25 conseillers le président a fait le
choix de réduire la taille des cabinets
bon c'est un choix il faut savoir que
les cabinets nombreux ces français c'est
à dire vous allez en allemagne ou en
italie en fait le ils ont des cabines
est extrêmement réduit et ils font
travailler l'administration et donc
c'est le modèle qui a été retenu par un
président et le premier ministre ça met
un peu de temps à s'adapter ça fait
beaucoup de tension sur les équipes mais
bon voilà c'est le sait le choix après
je vous lis à l'administration derrière
il ya quand même sur un certain nombre
de sujets quand on parle numérique
éducation je travaille avec jean michel
blanquer on n'est pas toujours d'accord
mais on arrive à travailler ensemble
quand je travaille par le numérique et
santé je travaille à ibiza idem voilà ça
se passe relativement
relativement bien et par ailleurs ma
vraie force en fait en tant que
secrétaire d'état au numérique c'est que
qu'on parle pas enfin comparativement
aux anciens gouvernements l'ancien
président c'est un sujet qui intéresse
beaucoup le président de la république
et donc je pense sa connaissance du
sujet en tout cas des paramètres globale
du sujet de comment ça se passe et sa
volonté de travailler le sujet au niveau
national qu'au niveau international est
très supérieur à beaucoup de chefs
d'état par le passé est par ailleurs
beaucoup de chefs d'états dans le monde
en entier c'est ça qui fait que j'ai une
certaine traction dans ce que je fais
revenons à nos moutons donald trump et
les etats-unis et la france en laisse
ils ont des moyens de rétorsion fenomeno
sur sur le marché français sur le marché
vos gains ils ont une justice un bras
armé est en plus doté de la nsa de tout
un tas de d'organismes leur permettant
de faire de l'intelligence économique
d'une façon profonde qu'est ce que fait
la france pour se protéger des états
unis
alors c'est une question
très vaste
d'abord je pense que je vais vraiment
prendre les cieux de l'est sujet par des
sujets basique mais rattrapé mois ci
c'est le problème d'abord je pense que
lui une d un des facteurs de la
domination notamment dans le numérique
des états unis c'est les gaffes a cédé
gaf a c'est à dire que on est dans un
monde où un winner takes it all comme on
le dit en bon français c'est à dire le
gagnant emporte tout est le gagnant
fixer la norme il ya un seul réseau
social il ya un seul je caricature parce
que des alternatives mais grosso modo en
termes de parts de marché donc il ya un
seul réseau social facebook et google
c'est la messagerie dominante gmail
c'est la seule l'application de
cartographie à open street map etc mais
en termes d'utilisation de force est
constater que par le grand public il ya
quelques nouvelles maps ces deux tiers
des téléphones dans le monde en termes
d'opérations système et on le voit c'est
le leader fils la fixe le principe
l'europe a été incapable pour plein de
raisons des raisons de financement des
raisons d'état d'esprit des raisons
de culture de faire émerger des leaders
qui soit à la hauteur des gaffes l'égide
américaine en a au nom les chinois han
han avec alibaba et tencent et nous au
milieu on en a aucun donc la première
chose au delà de toutes les lignes de
défense qu'on pourra penser en termes de
régulation en termes de contre-mesures
bla bla bla c'est d'avoir des leaders
qui fixe la norme c'est pour ça que la
question des start up et la question de
faire émerger des entreprises
technologiques qui soit au niveau de la
compétition mondiale elle est hyper
importante et pour moi c'est une de mes
premières priorités notre temps non
c'est pas trop tard tu sais pas trop
tard pour revenir sur les chiffres le
développement de ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler la french tech etc c'est pas
trop tard je pense qu'il ya encore des
choses qui se joue il ya encore des
technologies par exemple reprenez le
calcul quantique dans lequel on a la
capacité et on a les cerveaux on peut
jouer donc on peut jouer mais maintenant
il faut investir plus il faut créer les
conditions notamment photo ch
g ou prendre un exemple les la france
dépense 2 2% de son pib dans son premier
intérieur brut en recherche et
développement le pays baissé de 1500
milliards d'euros donc fait deux fois de
1500 ça fait de faire
le calcul je vais pas le faire en direct
je dis juste ça je donne cet exemple la
france dépense 2,2 pour cent de son pib
c'est moins que la moyenne des pays
développés c'est moins que l'apn des
pays développés qui doit être autour de
2,7
l'allemagne dépense aujourd'hui 3% de
son pib en recherche et développement
elle a pour ambition d'aller à 3,5 en
2025 si l'allemagne je prends ça à
l'intérieur de l'europe si l'allemagne
est à 3 5% de son pib dépensés en
recherche et développement
comparativement à nous qui sommes à 2,2
en 2025 si on ne fait pas d'effort ses
60 milliards d'euros 60 milliards
d'euros qui seront dépensés chaque année
en plus par l'allemagne dans la
recherche développement faut pas se
leurrer 1 au bout du bout c'est des
emplois et de la souveraineté et je
parle pas des chinois et je parle pas
des américains et donc il faut faire des
efforts il faut faire des effets plus
d'efforts dans la recherche la recherche
et développement nous on a présenté par
exemple un plan sur l'intelligence
artificielle de l'année dernière il faut
qu'on fasse plus d'efforts mais l'effort
il doit se faire collectivement au
niveau des européens parce que quand je
siffle cite les chiffres que je que je
citais il faut que l'europe investisse
plus et qu'elle fasse des choix ont fait
des choix de dépenses de dépenses dans
nos grands choix de dépenses dans le
social etc les autres pays font des
choix de dépenses de long terme dans la
r&d il ya personne qui va manifester
aujourd'hui parce qu'on ne dépense pas
assez dans la r d mais quand vous encore
des gens magnifiques mais le problème
c'est que du coup on
dépense de l'argent là où les gens
manifestent mais c'est le problème c'est
le long terme sur le long terme on
condamne en partie l'avenir nos enfants
il ya des questions qui sont en train
d'arriver je suis désolé je passe un
message à la communauté fait des
questions je chante les gars
revenons revenons aux états unis est ce
que les états unis sont toujours nos
alliés en termes de business ou pas du
tout ou est-ce que c'était une un conte
de fées une légende qu'ont expliqué aux
enfants c'est à dire les états unis sont
nous allier ya pas de problème où ils
sont ils sont venus dans une politique
commerciale et d'intelligence économique
très très agressive
les on peut être les alliés de quelqu'un
sans être naïf
donc les états unis sont et seront
toujours c'est mon opinion je prendrais
c'est l'opinion du grévin le français
des alliés de la france après s'être
porte justement il se comporte mal dans
plein de domaines et donc tu vois pas
être naïf ce qu'il dit ce sont ben arfa
et se comporte mal si vous regardez ce
que raconte snowden ce que raconte voilà
donc on sait qu'ils se sont mal
comportés je vais pas faire de
commentaire sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'ils ont un peu corrigé mais
donc ce sont des alliés et si vous
voulez je ne fais pas de parallèle entre
les états unis et la chine c'est à dire
que les états unis sont des alliés les
chinois sont des partenaires commerciaux
mais ce ne sont pas des alliés au même
titre que les états unis quand on a
besoin de faire des échanges entre
services de renseignement quand on a
besoin de s'engager dans sur des
théâtres d'opérations ils sont rudes
mais ils sont la première chose est
d'ailleurs historiquement quand on le
voit le général de gaulle a toujours eu
une relation extrêmement
de la voix française mais au moment où
il ya eu la crise des missiles de cuba
il a clairement dit si jamais il ya une
guerre entre l'urss et les états unis
nous serons là et je pense que quelque
part ne continuent de ça ce que je pense
qu'ils changent encore plus avec donald
trump
c'est que quand donald trump dit
aux européens la syrie c'est votre
problème pas le mien je pense que c'est
un tournant extrêmement important dans
les relations
on va dire géopolitique mondiale ça ne
veut pas dire que les états unis ne sont
plus nos alliés ça veut dire que
l'europe doit cesser de se considérer
comme un partenaire junior des états
unis il avait dit rien je veux dire
quand vous avez dire que mais parce que
alors j'ai enfin il faut aller dans un
peu dans le détail c'est à dire que la
question de la souveraineté qui est
hyper importante pour les français il
part importante parce que ç'a toujours
été important pour nous parce qu'on a la
bombe nucléaire parce que charles de
gaulle parce que derrière derrière et
ses servantes jusqu'à napoléon y en a
une certaine idée de notre va y est
voilà la question la souveraineté qui
est très importante pour les français ce
qu'il faut que les européens les
français comprennent c'est que elle
l'est beaucoup moins en général est
historiquement pour les pour les autres
européens les allemands les pays
nordiques sont attachés à leur
souveraineté mais au bout du bout leur
sécurité est assurée par le parapluie
nucléaire américain a été assurée
historiquement par le parapluie
nucléaire américain est donc la relation
notamment dans les domaines souverain
avec les états unis n'est pas forcément
la même que la nôtre le fait que le
président trump dit ça c'est à dire
qu'en fait quelque part votre sécurité
c'est votre sujet avant d'être le mien
ça ça pousse quand même l'europe à se
penser de plus en plus comme une europe
puissance ce qui n'est pas du tout la
culture notamment des pays du nord dans
europe les pays du nord ne pense pas en
terme d' europe puissance mais voilà il
ya des changements l'émergence de la
chine laisse le changement d'attitude
des etats-unis est donc quelque part ça
valide la théorie française qui est de
dire il faut qu'on ait notre propre voie
ça veut dire que il faut qu'on soit on a
abandonné certaines briques de
technologies qui sont absolument
critique comme par exemple cloud mais on
n'a pas d'acteurs qui sont capables ces
critiques pourquoi expliqué alors ces
critiques parce que aujourd'hui de plus
en plus sentir les filets ont fait une à
chaque fois des inserts mais pourquoi
aujourd'hui de plus en plus des données
sont dans le cloud c'est à dire que vous
les avez pas chez vous dans votre
ordinateur dans votre petite machine
mais en fait elles sont sur un grand sur
un serveur c'est c'est quelque part ce
qui est acquis sur un serveur qui
prêtent aux états unis qui peut être en
france qui peut être en chine vous le
savez pas mais en fait tout et tout et
le chaos quand vous regardez une vidéo
sur youtube je prends cet exemple-là la
vidéo c'est pas une vidéo vous avez
enregistré chez vous c'est une vidéo qui
est sur un serveur aux états unis et
donc de plus en plus de choses notamment
avec le streaming c'est à dire que vous
faites des choses monsieur voter sur
votre téléphone sont aux états-unis ou
ailleurs le problème c'est que les plus
gros fournisseurs de cloud sont
américains ils sont en chinois mais en
tout cas pour ce que les usages français
sont américains c'est microsoft c'est
amazon et c'est google les trois qui
fournit ce club et donc comme les îles
trois bandes ayons des petits
partenariat avec l'armée américaine
alors des trois c'est déjà les trois ne
se comportent pas de l'animé par exemple
les états unis les entreprises
françaises prennent un risque en
utiliser mieux lotis des états unis ont
édicté une
règle de loi qu'on appelle
extraterritoriale c'est qu'ils ont dit
qui veut que à partir du moment où une
entreprise française travaille avec l'un
de ses fournisseurs dont le siège social
de la maison mère et aux etats-unis
alors d'une certaine manière ces données
ne sont pas protégés vis-à-vis de la
justice américaine et donc l'entrée
données de la société peuvent être
saisies par les etats unis sans que
l'entreprise elle même ne soit prévenue
et donc ça pose un énorme problème en
terme de souveraineté sauf que comme en
fait y'a pas de fournisseurs de cloud
alors il ya des fournisseurs de plaintes
qui font des trucs très bien en
dans certaines niches qui ce comme ovh
com à votre cas il est des choses comme
ça mais qu'ils n'ont pas le même
puissance que les américains en fait on
ne sait même pas protéger nos
entreprises du fait que les américains
aient cherché leur donnait alors même
que la justice française n'est pas
prévenu et donc on le voit quand on
abandonne une brique technologique quand
on abandonne une partie de quelque chose
qui fait la souveraineté d'un état mais
on n'est plus souverain c'est dire que
les américains ils peuvent décider de
manière unilatérale d'aller chercher les
données de les donner à la justice pour
qu'elle enquête
de manière si ça l'intéresse sur un
sujet sans que l'entreprise ni la
justice française sont au courant et
puis à la ville afin de condamner
l'entreprise et donc comme alstom je
vais pas commenter des pourquoi en
commission un système particulier parce
que je ne commenterai pas des situations
pareilles ce tome filieris frédéric piot
uci qui a fait plus de 25 morts en
prison qui a été moyen de pression sur
la boîte alstom pour qu'elles soient
vendues mais je ne commente pas les
légumineuses l'afrique je ne commande
pas les dossiers particuliers mais en
tout cas je pense que vous me rejoindrez
sur le fait que en fait en abandonnant
certaines briques technologiques mais on
a besoin de certaines part de nos
souverainetés c'est c'est aussi simple
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est comme
quand vous exportez
des avions avec de la technologie
américaine les américains peuvent à un
moment refusé que vous exportez vos
avions ou que vous utilisez que vous
utilisez vos avions un certain certains
parce que en fait il sait nous les
composants donc on voulait fournir un
pas donc voilà ça veut dire que l'europe
doit se penser comme une puissance dans
le monde qui vient ça veut pas dire
qu'on n'est plus allé avec les
américains ça veut dire que on doit
pouvoir défendre leurs propres intérêts
vous avez parlé de snowdon snowdon un
songe
les écoutes sont nés ou là est ce que
votre ministère en particulier a pris
des dispositions pour éviter de non-dits
éviter de se faire poney
se faire infiltrer est-ce que vous avez
pris des mesures spéciales est-ce que
vous avez un terminal sécurisé avec un
os français un chiffrement français avec
des choses française derrière alors non
on a juste pour dire ce qu'on a on
dispose moi j'ai deux terminaux enfin
j'ai deux téléphones portables et deux
ordinateurs et donc j'ai un terminal
mais j'ai un iphone comme tout le monde
et j'ai un terminal sécurisé qui permet
de machines qui ne sert à rien c'est ça
non non c'est un samsung cette voie
cette hausse n'était plus alors il est
sécurisé donc effectivement on peut pas
mettre toutes les applications mais ça
c'est la vie aussi par qui parle ainsi
donc l agence à ce système pay ou
d'informatique informatique pardon qui
en fait c'est que fait toute la sécurité
informatique de de l'état moi j'ai deux
terminaux
voilà je les beaux
99 % de mes communications j'utilise mon
terminal normal quand j'ai besoin de
passer un coup de fil qui touchent des
sujets sensibles j'utilise les terminaux
sensibles vos dispositions d'hygiène
informatique c'est quoi on la majeure
partie du temps vous avez des
préconisations à faire un autre
communauté en termes d'hygiène
informatique
de fait il y en a plein que j'imagine je
connaissais bien sûr l'utilisation des
clés usb moi je change mes clés usb une
fois par mois
o au minimum sur le fait
de
ne pas laisser traîner toute enseigne où
c'étaient ses téléphones de après en
règle générale de ne pas ouvrir les
courriels un peu bizarres ou en tout cas
si votre grand mère vous écris pour vous
dire qu'elle est bloquée au cameroun où
quelqu'un dont vous n'avez pas une
nouvelle vous écris pour vous dire que
avec un orthographe un peu bizarre pour
voilà bon en règle générale je pense
qu'il faut être assez méfiant bon avec
quelques règles assez simples que chacun
trouvera sur internet je pense qu'on
évite 99% des problèmes et puis les mois
évidemment j'ai une fonction spéciale
j'ai des relations spécifiques je touche
à des sujets qui font que je me suis
probablement la cible
d'intérêt de gens de diverses natures et
d'ailleurs
puisque vous aborder ce sujet pendant la
campagne présidentielle on dit que
j'étais trésorier d' emmanuel macron
c'est mes emails qui ont été piratés par
qui je ne sais pas mais c est mes emails
qui ont été piratés bon ça l'est
toujours pas non j'ai pas
si nous on devait vous attrapez on vous
ciblera pas vous directement ciblés au
rayon priorités votre femme de ménage ou
à une puce trois
revenants revenons à nos moutons sur les
questions de surveillance
vous avez déjà été à l'ambassade
américaine non jamais non ça vous dirai
pas qu'on avait visité le dernier étage
de l'ambassade américaine
je vois où vous voulez en venir mais je
veux revenir ou moi je sais pas moi j'ai
entendu le fait qu'ils avaient des
antennes mais j'en sais rien donc je
connais les rumeurs dans l'équipe qui
veulent qu'il y ait 10 positive mais je
sais même pas quelle est leur
matérialité voilà donc je lance à
la et sur snow données assange est ce
que la france se doit
après après les révélations de snowdon
se doit de leur donner l'asile
est ce que la france a le pouvoir de
leur donner l'asile est ce que les
mesures de rétorsion si la france donne
asile à snowdon seront importantes de
par les états unis est ce que à ce que
la france doit faire un geste pour
edouard snowdon ou pour julian assange
alors
rappelez vous que ce nous donne a révélé
sundance et les écoutes de la nsa et
d'autres choses aussi pardon x et x
qu'est score et des choses comme ça
alors j'ai pas tous en tête en étant un
jeu leur disons que le gros s'efface qui
a fait le
ski a fait la une c'est elle et les
écoute
et à sang chez celles et c'est ce qui
s'est passé en irak ta mémoire un
latéral des matches
exactement
d'abord ça donne il n'a pas demandé
l'asile ici
pour l ai pas demandé l'asile en france
et assange son fils est en france
assange pour moi c'est un peu différent
mais je connais pas suffisamment le
sujet de son dauphin de sujets
juridiques
je dirais surtout tribunal de san
situation wikileaks est sûre je fais pas
de parallèle entre assange et snowdon
pour moi assange
ce qui me gêne quelque part
c'est que et c'est toujours un problème
c'est que pour moi
notamment dans la campagne américaine
wikileaks sert les intérêts d'une
puissance étrangère a dit le dit lumumba
et des russes puisque c'est
je trouve que c'est une responsabilité
c'est alors je pense que quand je n'ai
pas l'état d'esprit des hackers ni de
cette donc je peux difficilement mettre
à leur place mais
je pense qu'il faut toujours réfléchir
aux conséquences de ce que l'on fait au
delà des principes intangibles et je
pense qu'on en parlera tout à l'heure ce
que j'imagine vous allez me parler de la
ppl avia et des choses comme ça
la loi est de la loi de lutte contre la
haine mais je pense que on peut pas
vivre dans un monde où on réfléchit sans
penser aux conséquences conséquence
finale de ce que l'on fait c'est à dire
que
si la conséquence finale de ce que vous
faites
c'est que un autre pays puissent choisir
puisse influer je sais pas si c'est
choisir sur les résultats de l'élection
de votre pays ou d'un autre pays parce
que en fait ça aura été stib il devra
cibler un camp et pas l'autre
je pense que la question se pose de
par exemple la question aurait pu se
poser de savoir quand est-ce que les
informations doivent être révélées je
prends l'exemple de macronix
il ya une décision
de des médias parce que c'était la
veille d'être 2e tour de dire nous ne
faisons pas mention de cet état de fait
parce que c'est la veille de l'élection
et demain et que c'est susceptible de
perturber l'élection présidentielle et
qu'on n'a pas du tout leurs oeufs le
recul même pour analyser ce qu'il ya
dedans je trouve que c'est une quelque
chose de responsables c'est une décision
de retrait responsable ce qui ne les a
pas empêchés après l'élection de dire ce
qu'il y avait de de passer à travers
tous mes emails y en avait dix mille
plus tous les audi mais les autres
personnes et de dire ce qu'il y avait
dedans et donc ils n'ont pas caché qu'il
y avait eu cette fuite etc mais mais je
trouve que voilà il ya une certaine
responsabiliser la question se pose de
deux
ans viendra peut-être après on viendra
après la loi la loi de lutte contre la
haine en ligne mais la question se pose
des résultats de ce qui est de ce qui se
passe
donc pas il peut pour julian assange à
ce stade non est ce que la france s'est
positionné sur les questions de torture
où près de son enfermement est ce qu'il
ya comme son fils est en france est ce
qu'il ya des relations diplomatiques
avec le gouvernement anglais
extrêmement france et pas du tout moi
qui gère ça c'est jean yves le drian
donc j'en ai aucune idée une question
d'internet belot de benoît qui nous dit
emails piratés lrm google a annoncé que
c'était les russes la france aucun
matériel pour le vérifier il faut-il
croire google la france n'attribue
jamais les attaques informatiques donc
la france n'a jamais alors n'attribuera
j'en sais rien c'est elle sait pas le
faire
elle il faut savoir que dans le monde en
termes de capacité informatique dans le
monde occidental il ya les américains
qui domine tout le monde de plusieurs
années pour le monde avance les français
ne sont reconnus pour être assez bons
notamment la dgse ou la dg à 6 à faire
un certain nombre de choses
je vois sourire mais je fait que
reporter ce que je vois et égaux compris
je souris parce qu'il avait vu un petit
1 2me scandale de montres connecter le
numéro deux de la dgse ces faits spots
et par jean marc manach jusqu'au pied de
chez lui parce qu'il avait nous
connecter et donc je souris pour ça oui
mais donc je je pense qu on a certaines
capacités nous n'attribuons jamais les
attaques et donc la france ne réagira
pas pour dire si c'est untel ou unetelle
pour pas me faire perdre la face non non
à l'or papier du
post qui dit edouard snowdon demande
l'asile à emmanuel macron l'ancien
employé de la cia aujourd'hui réfugié en
russie publie sa première autobiographie
mémoire vive et réitère sa demande
d'asile à la fréquence
justin qui bougeait pas le papier date
de
e le papier date du 16 09 2010 9
je le savais pas
mais encore une fois je vais répondre
vraiment très honnêtement merci tout
pics
ces dossiers là qui sont des dossiers
géopolitiques ne sont pas gérées par le
secrétaire d'état numérique mais par
c'est pas une manière de détourner le
truc mais bon tant que personne et en
tant que personne ok on met de côté le
fait que vous soyez ministre
je sais que c'est difficile
les ministres du numérique en général
sont plus cool que les autres missiles
sont déjà plus jeunes comprenez
comprennent ce qui se passe donc c'est
plus sympa
snowdon a prouvé que nous entreprise
était complètement en short voir en slip
par rapport à la nsa a montré que la nsa
développer des outils qui était
complètement en dehors de toute
réglementation est foulée aux pieds
toutes les conventions des droits de
l'homme et j'en passe et des meilleurs
vous en tant que personne en tant que
cédric au qui a grandi à lyon en tant
que lyonnais et l'ayant mariage
civil un fort caractère si non je trouve
que les partis vers et pour le prix
génie des réponses jusqu'à ce que je
fait un le sujet du cas perso snowdon
comment ça se passe de l'ex-star je ne
connais pas hyper bien donc je
je vais répondre c'est à dire que moi je
trouve qu'il a fait est utile et je
trouve que ce qu'il a fait est utile à
la france
pour l'ensemble de pour la france a dans
une certaine mesure ça nous a permis de
découvrir un certain nombre de choses
c'est utile pour l'ensemble des des pays
développés et des pays démocratiques et
ça permet de dénoncer des choses qui
sont inacceptables
après je ne connais pas suffisamment le
dossier pour savoir si moi je considère
qu'on doit lui donner l'asile ou pas je
vous le dis aussi aussi clairement ça
est ce que c'est bien ce qu'il a fait
willy est ce que c'est le tout est que
dans le cadre des relations
internationales je sais tout non c'est
pas moi qui gère le dossier donc je n'en
sais rien est-ce que vous pouvez passer
des messages de jean-yves pour
les charges ont distrait et jean yves
cesson dossier puisque le mien je pense
qu'il ya des applications qui vont
beaucoup plus loin que c'est que moi je
peux voir
c'est à dire la versatile j'en ai plus
de riom cela on l'a vu on l'a vu avec le
sommet en russie ukraine là il est
arrivé ça de près si l'année des cernes
ouais alors j'arrive de dorian ça fait
quelques temps que je le connais j'ai
depuis la campagne présidentielle de
françois hollande 2012 en 2012 je serai
je ne fais pas beaucoup de souci pour
lui je pense qu'il est peut-être fatigué
mais ça continue à tourner très vite et
je pense que c'est pas le dernier des
neuf
revenons revenons à nos moutons
en terme d'intelligence artificielle est
ce que la france est prête quand on
entend laurent alexandre dire que
l'intelligence artificielle forte va
ravager tout un secteur d'activité va
agir dans la vie de l'intelligence
certes il est force et la singularité
non non tu imagines certifie
se rapprochant d'eux alors d'abord je
suis pas un spécialiste à dire que je ne
suis pas un chercheur donc mon point de
vue mais que la l'opinion que je me suis
fait pour pour le coup avoir discuté
avec beaucoup de chercheurs ont pensé
des déclarations de laurent alexandre
alors je connais très bien laurent
alexandre
je vais dire quelque chose qui va
vraiment vraiment lui déplaire alors que
je m'entends bien avec lui je pense que
c'est un peu la greta tanberg de la
technologie et c'est très drôle parce
qu'il dit en fait que greta tanberg elle
passe son temps à dire qu'on va mourir
et que elle a une forte responsabilité
parce que c'est pas en disant tout les
jours qu'on va mourir que
que l'on va s'en sortir et que je perds
elle dit elle dit peut-être qu'on va
mourir mais le détour surtout savez
douloureux juste avant oui voilà bon et
et laurent alexandre dit sensiblement la
même chose c'est-à-dire qu'il dit on est
mort va se faire bouffer par les
américains et les chinois ils sont
beaucoup plus intelligents que nous
d'ailleurs parfois il détruit qui sont
honnêtement un peu border mais avec
toute l'affection nord mais sur une
réflexion j'ai dit et c'est ouais il va
répondre qu'il est nos scientifiques etc
mais grenouille et il veut dire ce qui
est drôle parce qu'il dit souvent
surtout ne répétez pas ce que je vais
vous dire mais bon peu importe c'est pas
le sujet
ce que je pense mais je pense que c'est
aussi très marqué par mon
ma moitié coréenne
je fais un détour la corée en 1960 c'est
le pays le plus pauvre du monde le plus
pauvre du monde c'est à dire qu'ils sont
plus pauvres que le ghana c'est la corée
du sud après la guerre de corée 1950
1953 la corée du sud et plus pauvre que
la corée du nord elle la dépasse dans
les années 70 juste souvenir de ça
cinquante ans plus tard à quel prix
c'est la onzième puissance et que d'un
kilo je finissais la onzième puissance
économique mondiale ce développement
c'est celui que mon père il a vécu mon
père qui faisait partie d'une famille
très aisée en corée du nord a tout perdu
sa famille a tout perdu dans la guerre
de corée et ils sont repartis plus
pauvres parmi les plus pauvres cinquante
ans plus tard ils font partie des
premières puissances économiques
mondiales et mon père m'a toujours dit
une chose on n'avait rien on n'avait pas
de de ressources de matières premières
on s'est dit que la seule chose sur
lequel on pouvait compter c'était
l'éducation et donc ils ont tout investi
dans l'éducation et c'est aujourd'hui
reconnu comme l'un des deux ou trois le
système est communauté éducative
demander plus performant avec un certain
nombre de dérives sur lesquels on
reviendra mais est aujourd'hui la france
elle elle l'a alors le système éducatif
français dysfonctionnements partie on ne
voit dans les tests pisa mais en termes
de recherche en ia si vous prenez tous
les patrons negafa dans la recherche une
bonne partie des patrons d'edf a cédé
français c'est jérôme pesenti eliane le
15 chez facebook sheholli et bousquet
chez google c'est rémy noche dit mind
cellule julia chez samsung enfin le
cafard et des grandes entreprises
technologiques international donc le
sujet qu'on a dans un monde qui va très
très vite c'est de faire en sorte que
ses ventes ces chercheurs qui sont les
meilleurs du monde parce que la bataille
pour l'intelligence artificielle c'est
d'abord une bataille pour l'intelligence
humaine ont créé les conditions pour
qu'ils puissent investir ici qu'ils
restent ici qui partent pas aux états
unis ça veut dire des conditions
salariales aussi il faut pas se cacher
les choses ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils puissent investir et à voir le
retour de leur investissement qui puisse
faire grandir leur boîte ici et je suis
persuadé qu'on peut se battre ça
nécessitera des efforts des efforts
financiers des efforts de cadre de
régulation mais on allait on allait
cerveau les chercheurs français tout à
l'heure j'étais avec luc julien julia
c'est un ancien de chez apple qui a créé
si le créateur de syrie qui est le
patron qui est spécialisée en
intelligence sociale qui est le patron
de la r&d chez samsung il me dit cédric
c'est simple les meilleurs c'est le
nôtre il dit moi j'ai vu standford j'ai
vu berkeley ils sont moins bons que les
nôtres donc le sujet on a les cerveaux
et la bataille dans la technologie dans
le monde c'est une bataille de cerveau
donc le problème il est plus facile que
si on n'avait pas les universités et les
cerveaux et les grandes écoles le
problème c'est qu'il faut qu'ils restent
ici qui créent leur boîtier et qu'on
crée les conditions pour qu'il fasse
grandir la boîte 6 mai donc oui je suis
persuadé qu'on peut qu'on peut qu'on
peut se battre et là où je suis en
désaccord avec leur alexandre et je suis
je pense qu'il faut s'y mettre je pense
qu'il faut y aller je pense qu'il faut
je crois un exemple qui peut un peu
étrange choquée la
quand on écoute la question de l'impôt
sur la fortune la question de l'impôt
sur la fortune et la casquette millien
ses seins oui et la question de du
prélèvement forfaitaire unique la
question du prélèvement forfaitaire
unique on l'a caricaturé comme un cadeau
pour les riches bon on est dans un monde
qui est mondialisé où la finance elle
est mondialisée c'est pas moi qui l'ait
décidé la mondialisation et l'ouverture
des capitaux financiers c'est françois
mitterrand c'est comme ça on pourrait
considérer que ça fonctionnait mieux
dans notre manière mais c'est comme ça
et par ailleurs les français
investissent beaucoup leur argent dans
la pierre et les obligations d'état à
travers l'assurance vie on a besoin de
l'argent des étrangers pour faire
grandir nos entreprises c'est malheureux
mais c'est comme ça et l'argent comme
ils véhiculent librement si vous avez
des endroits où il est plus taxé il
vient - et donc là si on veut être une
puissance technologique si on veut être
une puissance souveraine si on veut
créer des offres d emploi on doit faire
en sorte d'attirer des capitaux de
partout dans le monde et de faire en
sorte que la fuite de capitaux français
s'investissent pas à l'étranger et donc
dans un monde qui est celui qui est tel
qu'il est il va vous devez faire en
sorte que votre fiscalité elle soit au
niveau des autres quand on fait le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique et quand
on fait on re module isf en dix ans en
fait on ne taxera pas le capital 6
investi dans l'entreprise mais c'est
c'est vital c'est vital moi je ne fais
pas on ne fait pas ça moi je suis à fond
pour je ne fais pas ça pour faire
plaisir à bernard arnault ou quelqu'un
de moche m'en fiche je le fais parce que
les 40 milliards d'euros qui
s'investissent aux états unis qui sont
la seule chose qui leur permet de tenir
tête aux chinois et ne pas faire en
sorte que toutes leurs boîtes et tout
leur job il part chez les chinois se
sont lassés de l'argent privé jamais
l'état va mettre 40 milliards d'euros
quand il sait pas trouver 10 milliards
pour financer les retraites et donc si
on veut faire en sorte d'être au niveau
de la compétition technologique pas pour
être au niveau de la compétition
technologique en soi mais pour avoir les
boîtes les emplois et la souveraineté
dont on parlait tout à l'heure pour
éviter de dépendre des états unis mais
on est obligé de le faire et donc je le
dis parce que je pense que quand on dit
il faut qu'on fasse des efforts pour
être dans la course de la compétition
sur l'ia et c'est pas le
jeudi qu'on peut encore de l'être je
pense que le timer le ton l'horloge
tourne et que donc tout vers les efforts
vite mais ça fait partie des efforts
qu'il faut faire bien sûr que ça veut
dire au bout du bout formellement que
certaines perdre un seul gars ne gagnant
plus d'argent mais c'est un dommage
collatéral si je veux dire qu'on peut
regretter mais en fait il faut prendre
le monde tel qu'il est et donc je ne
fais pas moi je ne paye pas le dsf pour
je n'ai gagné aucun à combien pardon
d'un rocco bien à quoi ils gagnent
basset public je dois gagner un vinyle
euros avant le prélèvement à la source
voilà donc je gagne j'ai
je n'ai pas de capital j'ai un
appartement à paris sur lequel il reste
le cas de 5e à rembourser j'ai pris un
prêt sur 25 ans mes parents m'avaient
pas de capital ma mère est retraitée
elle gagne 1500 euros net par mois à
l'habitat villeurbanne bon je ne fais
pas partie de ceux enfin je fais pas
bien quel sera votre mère qu'est ce
qu'elle pense de la réforme des
retraites
ma mère est historiquement de gauche
plus à gauche que moi et plus à gauche
que vous
alors moi non bah moi j'ai toujours mais
j'ai toujours considéré être de centre
gauche c'est à dire que je toujours été
la tendance rocard et ses jeux j'estime
encore je sais que c'est un débat qui
intéressera beaucoup de gens j'estime
encore être de gauche je n'ai aucun
problème avec ça ma mère elle a été
enseignante
voilà et a toujours voté socialiste
toute sa vie à part
en deux en 2002 au deuxième tour
et donc voilà elle est là et je pense
que comme une partie des gens de gauche
elle a du mal culturellement avec une
partie de la politique menée par
emmanuel macron
peut en débattre parfois un peu vivement
elle a du mal que tu as a man avec ça
et donc je vais pas parler de la réforme
des retraites bon on peut bien sûr la
forme d'un prêt moi je suis persuadé que
la femme reste une réforme de gauche je
sais que ça va choquer mais super c'est
françois fillon il ya une vidéo qui
tente sur l'année qui dit voilà
le coût de la retraite a poussé c'est
vachement bien parce que comme ça les
tailles 10000 là il diminue la valeur du
point et puis comme ça mais c'est parce
que c'est qu'une en fait la retraite
mettons pas la vôtre à table pendant la
retraite quand vous avez le chiffre qui
est il y avait quatre personnes qui
cotisent et quatre actifs pour un
retraité en 1950 vous en avez 1,7 actifs
qui cotisent aujourd'hui pour un
retraité les gens vivent plus longtemps
il commence à travailler plus tard et
donc vous avez moins de gens qui
travaillent moins longtemps pour plus de
gens qui vivent plus longtemps bon ben
il ya trois choses pour équilibrer
recettes à long terme ont même où on
n'aime pas mais c'est comme ça c'est
mathis et mathématiques soit vous
baisser les pensions c'est la solution
qui est évoqué par françois fillon
soit vous travailler plus longtemps soit
vous cotisez plus donc quand françois
fillon est dit que la retraite à points
elle
elle aboutit à la baisse des pensions
c'est pas vrai vous pouvez choisir de
travailler plus ou de cotiser plus nous
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on veut on ne va
pas mentir aux gens il faudra travailler
plus et c'est la condition pour ne pas
pour ne pas ni baisser les retraites ni
faire en sorte que
le que les que ceux qui travaillent
doivent cotiser plus je bâtis sur les
retraites parce que je fais le lien avec
les histoires d'intelligences intimes
parce que tout ça est lié
si on considérait qu'il ya une autre
manière qui est de dire on va taxer les
riches pour aller financer les retraites
et pour financer tout ça c'est cool
himmich c'est à partir de combien
collège jean sérien ça se pense que
chacun juge le revenu médian en france
il à 1500 euros 548 oui voilà il à 1500
euros le revenu moyen 1820 disons que
l'on va prendre de revenu médian c'est
plus intéressant mais le pourcentage de
la france actifs gagnent autour de 1500
euros
alors ça veut dire qu'il ya 50 % en
dessous de 8 82% voilà donc ça veut dire
82% de la france actifs qui gagne 1500
joue
aujourd'hui sa soeur c'est au tour de
1548 euros ces deux chiffres qui datent
de dominer et dressez vous prenez quoi
comme fourchette le lire c'est mille
trois cent mille sept cents chiots le
revenu moyen en france s ils sont 149 0
82% de la populaire le revenu médian
français c'est 1540 d'affaires lui
revenu moyen français ses 1800 euros ça
c'était les chiffres qui sont dans le
dans le rapport de piketty dans le livre
de piketty de 2000
2011 ces 1500 1800 ça a probablement a
peu évolué depuis mais médian pour moi
c'est 1500 moyens 5800
en tout cas c'est les chiffres à
l'époque je reviens parce qu'en fait je
veux continuer mon à développer mon ma
réflexion on peut dire aujourd'hui les
retraites il faut qu'on ne touche à rien
et quand le financent par en taxant les
riches
on est déjà l'un des pays qui taxe le
plus les hauts revenus et 10 % il ya que
45% des français qui payent l'impôt sur
le revenu et 10% des français payent 70
% de l'impôt sur le revenu les retraites
en france c'est 14% du pib français dans
les pays développés en moyenne ces 8 %
donc on peut considérer que c'est pas
assez mais on n'est déjà pas loin d'être
le pays le plus généreux est le plus
redistributif si on va encore plus loin
mais ça veut dire que dans un système
mondialisé et bien l'été les gens qui
investissent et qui investissent leur
argent dans les entreprises dans la
technologie dans la recherche qui demain
pour notre ferons notre richesse chez
nos emplois et bien non pas en france
ils devront le faire aux etats-unis en
allemagne donc on peut dire que il n'ya
pas de contrainte mais ce que je pense
fondamentalement c'est que être
responsabilité être
ministre être président de la république
c'est ne pas mentir aux gens et prendre
des décisions souvent prendre la
question c'est quelle est la moins
mauvaise des décisions en l'espèce je
pense que considérer qu'il ne faut pas
que le système des retraites s'est auto
c'est qu'il est par ailleurs et la
décision du conseil national de la
résistance en
1945 c'est de dire en fait le système
des retraites s'autofinance enfin non je
voulais parenthèses ses 82 % de la
population active en france qui touche
une rémunération moyenne à peine
supérieur au smic papier du 28 octobre
2014 l'ops
mal 541 euros brut en moyenne les noms
de cadres gagnent 1541 en brut en
moyenne ok mais voyez c'est assez
intéressant parce que si vous voulez si
vous si le sujet c'est de dire que vous
êtes riches
c'est à dire qu'il ya 15% un français
sur six seulement qui est au delà de chp
à 1600 1700 euros concerne tout ce que
vous dites
si je pense que ces gens là ne se
considère pas comme un riff j'ai
considéré comme riche et c'est assez
marrant parce que quand vous demandez si
vous demandez aux gens en fonction de ce
qu'ils gagnent dans quel pourcentage de
la population ils sont je pense si vous
étiez très fortement il trouve que quand
j'étais chez safran pendant un an et
demi j'ai travaillé dans les vignes de
safran non non non alors là je vais je
touchais mon cas mon salaire j'avais pas
le salaire d'un ouvrier d'une omlt
agents de maîtrise j'ai que tous
cherchent pas de l'or de 7000 euros nets
pardon je reviens et donc les ouvriers
chez safran ils sont relativement
bien payé par avance avait pas d'épée
mais ils doivent gagner je pars 2000
2500 euros net et je leur demandais à
votre avis
dans pourcentage dans combien de
français dans quel pourcentage vous êtes
des français qui gagnent mieux leur vie
et eux ils disaient ah ben je parle je
dois être à la moyenne alors qu'ils
étaient déjà dans les 10 % ou les 15%
quand c'est qu'il ya une question
d'internet et quid des 240 milliards
d'euros d'évasion fiscale en france par
an on ne peut pas les récupérer ce qu'on
peut pas récupérer cet argent en
question de chilliboy
alors s'il y avait eu alors il ya 18 ans
alpha fiscal des gains fans alors il ya
une différence entre
optimisation fiscale évasion fiable je
sais que pour les gens c'est la même
chose mais c'est une très grande
différence c'est à dire quand les gars
fin ils se mettent en irlande est il
fondé des montages techniques qui font
que nous on ne sait pas c'est légal mais
on ne sait pas aller le chercher
c'est pas forcément de ses pas de
l'évasion c'est à dire ce n'est pas
illégal
malheureusement c'est quoi ces algues
luna outre une optimisation c'est à dire
que
pour les gens c'est c'est la même chose
mais ce n'est pas la même chose c'est à
dire que vous n'avez pas le droit de
planquez vos impôts en suisse fin de
planquer votre argent en suisse mais par
contre vous avez le droit d'aller
investir dans des trucs qui vous
permettent de réduire votre impôt ou de
faire des montages financiers il pour la
limite parfois entre l'extrême
optimisation et l'évasion est très
compliqué aller chercher mais
quelques pas si il y avait de l'argent
dont c'était beaucoup plus simple que
c'était beaucoup plus simple allez
chercher on fait des choses contre
l'évasion fiscale j'ai pas les chiffres
mais maintenant on a montré qu' on a
récupéré plus d'argent qu'on en a jamais
récupéré dans les dernières années mais
moi je préférerais cent fois aller
récupérer de l'argent qui sait
frauduleusement mis à l'étranger et que
je peux aller également récupérer parce
que je sais pas ce que j'ai des
informations plutôt que de devoir faire
des effets vote demander des efforts aux
français cet politiquement ce serait
beaucoup plus simple donc si c'était
facile mais que ce soit nous les
socialistes avant nous enfin moi je
faisais partie de ce gouvernement ou
encore avant sarkozy ou encore les gens
leurs effets je veux dire il n'y a pas
de grand complot qui veut que en fait on
fait ça on fait ça pour faire qu'il faut
faire des cadeaux
la quantité des manifestations dans la
rue pour la réforme des retraites ça
risque de faire il prenait bien le point
de vue des français moi je vais prendre
simplement un exemple j'aurais pu poser
positionner une société en estonie gens
lui positionné m'associer tailleur et a
pas de rapatrier les bénéfices payés ep
% d'impôts et encore jusqu'à 100
millions ou en suisse c'est zéro
c'est légal sauf que par contre c'est à
dire conscience par conscience
patriotique parce que ma communauté paye
ses impôts en france nous finançons en
france je suis imposé avec le tarif
français parce que c'est normal et il
est chef d'entreprise ou les groupes qui
font du rapatriement bénéfices on y
renonce à gauche ou à droite
ils sont pas patriotes alors qu'ils font
leur fric empêcher d'accord alors on
fait comme on leur met des bâtons dans
les roues mais je vais vous vous posez
la question différemment on fait comment
on fait comment on sort de l'europe on a
en attendant voilà les troupes attaque
et l'irlande bon je commence par
luxembourg non mais quand le commandant
ce mets bien sûr que ça m'énerve bien
sûr que iliad et il ya des des
entreprises voire parfois des pays qui
peuvent avoir des comportements de
passager clandestin
donc je n'ai aucun oui je ne serai pas
de cas particulier mais il ya des choses
ce n'est pas normal d'où et quand ces
pays se mettent en travers de la taxe
diaphane ce n'est pas normal maintenant
on vit dans ce monde là au bout du bout
l'europe ça reste une chose extraits que
que dont l'apport ou du look me semble
positif donc faut pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain il ya des choses
extrêmement ambitieuse qui sont mises
sur la table par le président pour dire
ok en fait à 28 peu consensus ça reste
quand même très compliqué donc on va
commencer par faire des choses avec les
gens qui sont d'accord
faisons des attaques diaphane ddd
des programmes de recherche entre pays
qui sont d'accord bien sûr bien sûr que
l'europe c'est insatisfaisant bien sûr
que quand on va discuter avec les face
aux américains et que on a une attitude
et que certains autres pays qui ont plus
peur que nous des rétorsions me disent
ah maintenant en fait on n'a pas t'aider
c'est très agaçant sauf que voilà c'est
un combat continue il faut le combat est
de combattre et il n'y a pas d'autre
solution reste une question de michel
pourquoi le gouvernement freine-t-il le
recrutement des inspecteurs fiscaux
je sème sur michel vaillant je ne sais
pas répondre à cette question parce que
je sais pas comment se passe leur gré
pendant que d'autres questions que
pense-t-il de black rock black block
blacks mais c'est black rock black rock
aux blagues ne sait pas exactement là je
prends les deux blackrock blackrock
c'est une entreprise qui est un fonds de
pension
est mais j'ai vu des choses qui sont
assez
assez folle dernièrement sur internet en
disant brac blackrock fait du bénéfice
sur l'argent des petits épargnants fait
oui c'est sa fonction c'est à dire que
aux états unis il n'y a pas de système
de retraite par répartition c'est à dire
que on se dirige pas sur scène en france
non à ben justement je pense que la
route la réforme des retraites telle que
nous la proposons est l'aboutissement de
ce qui a été proposé par le conseil
national de la résistance c'est-à-dire
une retraite vraiment universel et là la
seule manière de faire en sorte que au
bout du bout on n'est pas soi des
retraits des réformes extrêmement dur
soit on aboutisse à la retraite par
capitalisation je reviens sur black rock
parce que c'était la question c'est
qu'est ce que je pense de blackrock
blackrock en fait c'est le petit
retraité enfin le petit instituteur le
petit travailleur du wisconsin qui comme
risque aussi de jeu pour ça que si
discussions mais le missouri fin j'en
sais rien bon qui comme lui il n'y a
personne qui va du pays sa retraite
c'est son argent qui va payer ce qui va
payer ces retraites et bien pas ils ne
cotisent pas auprès d'une caisse de
retraite il donne son argent à blackrock
et lui dit fait le fructifier pour que
je puisse me payer ma retraite et donc
blackrock il investit cet argent là pour
gagner de l'argent pour payer ensuite la
retraite et donc une blackrock qui joue
le col le rôle d'une
d'une caisse de retraite gérée par des
gens qui font la finance sauf que à
l'époque encadrés comme les caisses de
retraite que c'est une entreprise
systémique à plus de 6000 milliards de
dollars que si blackrock se vautre
passer tous ces petits épargnants qui se
vautre avec mais ça c'est le système par
capitalisation enfin je sais assez le
système qu'on choisit délibérément et
démocratiquement les américains je n'y
peux rien on va passer à un autre sujet
parce que là ce n'était pas le sujet de
l'émission d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
questions sur black rock on passe à la
reconnaissance faciale on revient il ya
beaucoup de questions sur sa tête
reposée de 3 après on va on va sauter du
coq à l'âne la reconnaissance faciale en
france c'est quoi c'est un système à la
chinoise qui dit pas son nom quand on
voit des technologies déjà opérationnels
pendu à la reconnaissance faciale
déployés sur le territoire genre les
radars tourelles qui sont capables de
prendre plus de 50 ou
les objectifs sont déjà opérationnels
pour ce type de technologie si on met si
l'on met derrière le sauve qui va bien
je pense que ça va tourner comme sur des
roulettes quand on voit par exemple
quand on voit par exemple
certaines certaines caméras de
vidéosurveillance et des avec un soft
derrière pour vérifier qu'il n'y ait pas
d'attroupement voilà ce que je dirai
qu'elle obtient rectangle orange le
petit rectangle vert le petit rectangle
rouge quand on voit ce type de
technologie se déployer en france un
pays qui a connu le nazisme des gens qui
faisait des fiches sur tout le monde des
gens qui faisaient la délation des gens
des choses comme ça c'est un pays de la
france est un pays qui a été marié
marqué par là la surveillance de la
gestapo des ss et des choses comme ça on
va parler pour le nôtre aujourd'hui
l'accord est bien entendu mais on va
parler d'une autre aujourd'hui la
reconnaissance faciale en france dans un
contexte social qui commence est
délétère
e
est-ce que c'est pas un risque est-ce
que c'est pas une canne technologique
pour pallier une insuffisance de
propositions politiques est ce que ce
n'est pas une canne technologique pour
encadrer une société qui est
profondément malade alors première chose
d'abord la reconnaissance faciale sans
consentement des gens n'est aujourd'hui
pas possible en france
la récompense je le répète
d'abord de quoi parader l'objectif
ladite onnaing et quadrature du net qui
vont être super content non mais
mais c'est la loi c'est à dire que sans
le consentement des gens
la reconnaissance faciale n'est
aujourd'hui pas permise en france la
cnil le dis très clairement donc
mettons déjà il faut de séparer d'eux de
définir ce qu'on dit quand on
reconnaissait on dit reconnaissance
faciale quand on dit reconnaissant
spatiale pour moi il ya deux cas
d'application qui pose des problèmes
différents dont l'un d'ailleurs pose
beaucoup moins de problèmes que l'autre
il ya l'authentification et il ya
l'identification
je définis ce que j'entends
l'authentification c'est j'utilise la
reconnaissance faciale pour
déverrouiller mon iphone pour possession
ou pour passer sur paraphe
l'identification
c'est j'utilise la reconnaissance
faciale pour trouver quelqu'un dans une
foule alors mon avis personnel
c'est que la reconnaissance faciale pour
authentifier pose assez peu de problème
dès lors qu'elle est bien encadré c'est
à dire que dès lors qu'on détermine le
les modalités des changes des données et
la conservation des données et qu' il ya
eu un comportement des gens et qu'il ya
éventuellement une possibilité de faire
la même action sans reconnaissance faite
sans passer par la reconnaissance
faciale je n'ai je trouve que mais c'est
mon avis personnel
les problèmes démocratiques sont posées
sont assez faibles c'est à dire que et
dès lors qu'on a la capacité de le
vérifier la première chose on avait
vraiment la capacité de vérifier mais il
faut il faut que les institutions qui
est fier mais c'est avec un faucon
yakafokon mois est-ce qu'on a la
capacité de vérifier sa d'ouvrir là le
capot derrière pour faire auditer ça
apporte tout le monde c'est possible
bien sûr si aujourd'hui la justice
s'intéresse un truc est de vérifier ça
j'ai pas deux fois oui mais c'est pas
vous aujourd'hui vous êtes protégé de ça
c'est à dire que si demain
apple n'applique pas le concert vos
données plus longtemps que etc la
justice est la capacité de vérifier
c'est juste que ça prend un peu de temps
mais l'incapacité de magie mais grosso
modo là je continue mon raisonnement la
reconnaissance sociale par
authentification pour authentifier les
gens je pense que c'est d'une part là
c'est le sens de l'histoire c'est à dire
que ça ouvre quand même beaucoup de
services ne serait ce que par exemple
pour s'identifier
sur des actes qui vous évite de vous
déplacer des choses comme ça demain pour
tous fiables pour tous alors je je ne
suis pas un technicien du sujet gd il ya
des débats
[Musique]
les industriels me disent que oui mais
c'est évidemment ils sont biaisés
les certaines associations de défense
des libertés disent que non mais
quelques pages je finis le fait que pour
authentifier ce soit pas fiable dès lors
qu'il ya toujours une voie traverse pour
le faire sans passer par la
reconnaissance faciale c'est pas très
grave c'est juste un peu embêtant que
vous vous puissiez pas de match par
retirer votre colis à toute heure
mais vous l'aurez pas accès à ce service
là c'est pas très grave c'est pas très
grave c'est à dire que pour authentifier
je parle vraiment dire que votre vous
puissiez pas déverrouiller votre iphone
avec votre visage mais que vous fassiez
votre code quelque part c'est juste un
service que vous n'avez pas donc je dis
ça d'abord authentification je pense ça
pose assez peu de problèmes première
question dès lors que c'est encadré ce
qui pose problème c'est la question
identification c'est à dire demain
j'utilise la reconnaissance faciale pour
reconnaître quelqu'un dans la rue
dans le cadre d'opérations de sécurité
ou pas énorme dans le cas de et des cas
de recherche de personnes disparues des
choses comme ça une personne âgée qui a
plus sa tête qui n'est ce pas ça ça pose
des questions c'est à dire où des
groupes de militants qui vont se faire
botter un spot est en fait vous utilisez
la façade pour
reconnaître quelqu'un dans la rue donc
après il ya plein d'utilisation qui sont
qui sont possibles là il ya plein de
questions qui sont peu qu'ils se posent
il ya des questions de dérive
effectivement dès lors que c'est utilisé
par des gouvernements à quelques
d'encadrement dave il ya des questions
de de fiabilité de la technologie que
vous évoquez et qui sont au coeur du
débat américain c'est à dire est ce que
la reconnaissance faciale sait
reconnaître les noirs et les femmes pour
le dire directement pire les femmes
noires
et il ya des questions
vas y à pleins de titien goya ces
différentes questions là ce que je
mon opinion à moi
c'est que
aujourd'hui le débat que nous avons est
largement fondée sur des fantasmes c'est
à dire que la plupart des gens qui
prennent position le prennent au regard
de ce qui se passe en chine qui n'est
absolument pas souhaitable jusqu'au stop
de seconde
je vais prendre la défense de ses fans
aux associations qui prennent position
sur des fantasmes
quand on voit que certains fichiers
deviennent les goûts que après avoir été
légiférer du moins des battues
correctement mais on sait que les
services de renseignement se gaver sur
certains fichiers alors que c'est tout à
fait illégal que ça devient légal que
par la suite c'est à dire que on
légalise des utilisations précédente qui
était ultra border vous comprenez bien
que ces associations l'année lll tu
prennes position parce que je vais
parler trivialement et je vais pas je
vais je vais tenir un peu vulgaire on
s'est déjà fait baiser alors eh oui je
vais répondre et donc le
jeu vous dire
d'abord si vous ne croyez pas dans les
institutions
alors faut tout arrêter si vous ne
croyez si on considère que les
institutions démocratiques
ne ne protège pas et moi je ne sais pas
débattre c'est à dire que moi je crois
en la loi je crois en l'état je crois
que l'état il est très imparfait et qui
mérite d'être
contrôlez d'éviter qu'il lui verse lui
même dans sa propre dérive et qu'il doit
y avoir un contrôle démocratique forme
je manquais la nef plus blatche et jeudi
laurence que l'état c'est nous je pense
que l'état c'est nous et que donc il
faut toujours poussé pour plus de
démocratie plus de démocratie plus de
contrôle démocratique et que les rats
l'état a une tendance à abuser de son
propre peut avoir une tendance à abuser
de son propre pouvoir dont il faut se
prémunir y compris quand on est un homme
politique mais je crois en l'état c'est
à dire que je crois en la validité des
institutions et si vous considérez que
les institutions
sont par nature
un faux nez de quelque chose d'autre ou
alors ne fonctionne pas ou alors que
vous ne croyez par l'état mais la
discussion est impossible parce que ça
veut dire que la discussion sur la
justice est impossible pour eux disent
qu'elles ces associations nous sommes
donc je pense alors je peux répondre sur
la la je reviens sur la reconnaissance
faciale et après on va au bout du bout
ce que je veux dire c'est que il est
nécessaire que d'abord je pense que le
travail je suis très souvent des
attentes en désaccord avec la quadrature
du net par exemple je pense vouloir
passer deux jours ils sont très utiles
et je pense que le travail est très
utile non mais je suis très souvent en
désaccord avec eux je pense qu'il est
bon que leurs opinions existent et qui
pousse les choses et que c'est la france
c'est que ça permet de trouver le point
d'équilibré bon voilà après
ils sont pas d'accord avec moi donc j'ai
pu je me dis mais je pense que c'était
une trêve il est heureusement qu'ils
sont là première chose tout comme
heureusement que ce lanceur des reds
dallaire son lac cet acte deuxième show
tj en france in motion la deuxième chose
juste au laissez moi finir sur la
reconnaissance faciale
sur
jusqu'où devant nous et aller dans la
reconnaissance faciale
je suis extrêmement partagées je vais je
vais l'expliquer d'abord je pense que
nous n'avons pas que nous nous parlons
sur des bases fantasmagorique
c'est-à-dire fantasmes et c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui moi je ne sais pas et
j'aimerais avoir des chiffres sur dans
quel état de tels cas d'utilisation
quels sont les faux positifs est-ce que
effectivement il ya un vrai problème
pour reconnaître les noirs et les femmes
est ce que on sait reconnaître combien
de temps combien de fois on s'est trompé
combien de fois on a détecté quelqu'un
qui était pas quelqu'un on a dit
quelqu'un n'était pas quelqu'un et c'est
donc la première chose et c'est ce que
le gouvernement a dit je pense qu'il
faut qu'ils aient on ouvre à des
expérimentations gevrey jeu parlement
d'expérimentation
pour sue la soul à la supervision de la
société civile et de la recherche pour
avoir un certain nombre de chiffres qui
sont on va dire donc on peut partager
c'est à dire je prends un exemple on
prend un cadre surveillance dans un
endroit on dit on prend 1000 personnes
qui passent pendant six mois dans un
endroit dont on sait qu'elle passe à un
endroit et on regarde combien de fois on
les a on les a récupérés on les a
repérés esquissons qu'on s'entende bien
sûr l'effet des personnes et on fait des
tests et ont dit oui ça marche ça marche
pas tel quel iphone portait toujours je
sais pas ce que vous faites référence
aux trucs des chinois bon non mais en
fait donc on fait des têtes dans
différentes configurations on dit
donc on prend tous les tous les cas d'
usage et on dit on fait des tests et on
regarde les chiffres
et sur cette base mais si ça marche pas
si effectivement c'est pas reconnaître
les mails et les noirs les femmes et on
en reparle quand on sait reconnaître les
droits des femmes je veux dire ccm -
c'est-à-dire faux pas voilà une fois
qu'on a les chiffres
eh ben on fait un débat moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un débat de
société qui disent qu'est ce qu'on fait
est qu'après les français ils doivent
d'une certaine manière choisir tout
comme on l'a fait sur le sur le débat
sur le comité national d'éthique ou à
part la pma on a quand même réussi à
arriver à un certain de consensus et je
pense qu'à partir les gens ils doivent
débattre parce que je suis totalement
conscience de la tension de l'eba c'est
à dire
que je
dans le cadre de la lutte antiterroriste
ça peut être utile ça peut être utile et
dont je suis mon argent je finis donc ça
peut être utile
et quelque part quand vous ne vous
donnez pas tous les moyens dans certains
cas dans des situations d'urgence pour
aller chercher les terroristes quand il
ya un attentat vous avez vous pouvez
vous avez quand même une responsabilité
et en même temps une fois que j'ai dit
ça je sais très bien que c'est toujours
l'argument qui sera utilisée par les
états pour justifier de la surveillance
de masse et donc j'ai tendance à penser
mais je n'ai je n'ai non seulement mon
raisonnement n'est pas que il faut par
ailleurs ça veut pas dire que tout peut
être ouvert tout le temps il peut y
avoir aussi des conditions ou sur la
surveillance d'un juge vous ouvrez des
choses et avec des systèmes d' escalade
et donc il faut à la fois débattre du
fond le cas échéant des systèmes de
contrôle et des systèmes démocratiques
de contrôle il faut se doter des
institutions qui vont avec et donc mes
mais je pense que ce débat il doit avoir
lieu et que on peut considérer que je ne
désespère pas de la démocratie et qu'on
peut avoir un débat
qui sera forcément passionnel qui sera
forcément là mais en se disant on essaye
entre gens
de bonne volonté
de se doter d'un corpus idéologique là
dessus je n'ai pas dîné à ce stade bien
sûr que je vois bien les dérives bien
sûr que je sais que ça sera toujours
l'argument terroristes qui sera utilisée
par les gouvernements pour mettre en
place des choses et en même temps on
peut pas écarter l'argument théorise
d'un revers de main et en même temps on
peut pas l'écarter vous avez plus de
chance de vous faire foudroyer que
mourir dans un attentat pardon vous avez
plus de chances de mourir foudroyé que
de mourir dans un attentat oui c'est
qu'on va faire cet arraisonnement le le
chiffre homo a sauté pour des questions
de terrorisme
enfin il a sauté ça dépend où c'est à
dire que whatsapp voulais faire plus moi
je trouve qu'il faut que c'est très bien
que watts a pas eu plus de faim que
facebook et le chiffrement enfin j'ai
plutôt pour pour le plaisir de fait le
fait qu'on donne son téléphone portable
et qu'on est obligé de donner le code
pin de son téléphone portable c'est bien
c'est pas bien vous êtes vraiment alors
si je connais pas extrêmement les sujets
mais vous êtes est obligé de donner le
code pin de téléphone portable sur
bois jeux alors honnêtement je ne suis
pas sûr
je vous n'êtes pas obligé de donner
quatre nouveaux téléphones portables et
si
vous être condamné pourrait pas donner
le code mais je ne savais pas bon
passons pendant mais c'est pas le sujet
mais donc le sujet il ya une question de
qui est très provoc
très provoc 2 n 6
qui dit question donc vous croyez en
l'état en tant que tel vichy c'était
sympa pour les interrogations vous
comprenez en fait cette question
provoque c'est à dire que les français
je dirais je dirais pas les français
mais une grande partie de la communauté
s'inquiète qu'on donne des lames de
rasoir à des singes mais sans capacité
de contrôle ou avait quoi que il ya des
erreurs terribles qu'on n'est jamais à
l'abri mais que si on ne croit pas en
l'état mais dans ce cas là on va tous
dans la zac dans une communauté et on
arrête tout alors je pense que tout est
perfectible je pense profondément que
évidemment il ya eu des dérives
vichystes c'était une dérive profonde de
l'état français mais oui l'état c'est
nous au bout du bout et donc que vous
l'appelez l'état où la communauté ou des
choses comme ça je ne connais pas
d'autre moyen de défendre l'intérêt
général et donc c'est une construction
humaine donc profondément elle fait des
erreurs humaines mais oui je crois et
avait donc vous proposer qu'on ait un
débat sur la reconnaissance je pense je
propose qu'on ait un premier temps
d'expérimentation sous la supervision
d'un certain nombre de personnalités
civiles de la cnil bla bla bla bla et de
chercheurs pour qu'on ait des choses
c'est qu'on mette en place des
expérimentations pour l'inclusion de la
couverture par exemple pardon ou
d'autres voilà jeu et
ensuite qu'on ait un débat de société
pourtant tueur de 2,3 sujet est ce que
vous connaissez les accords de wassenaar
non pas du tout
si par exemple on parlait de détaxe gaf
a est ce que la france a cette capacité
d'aller dire mais la c 4 % c'est 10 %
est ce qu est ce qu on a cette capacité
cette force légale ou dans les pressions
internationales
alors légalement oui c'est à dire que
vous pouvez dès lors que ce n'est pas
assimilable à un impôt sur les sociétés
de l'or que vous taxer le chiffre
d'affaires dans le cadre de la
convention fiscale avec les états unis
on est dans notre droit de créer la taxe
diaphane elle est au regard des
conventions internationales et du
multilatéralisme légal donc entre hommes
17 unilatérale ça ne veut rien dire bien
sûr si tu n'as terral c'est à dire que
les états unis je les ai pas souvent
entendu appeler la france au moment de
créer des taxes sur les entreprises qui
sont leurs territoires qu'elle soit
européenne chinoise et américaine pour
leur demander leur avis notre avis par
non donc nous quand on crée un impôt dès
lors qu'ils rentrent dans la cadre légal
de la convention fiscale avec les états
unis bas ont créé et on a la capacité de
le créer donc d'une bourse et donc c'est
légal après ce qui est unilatéral c'est
mais c'est pas encore décidé puisque
de consultation qui est ouverte sur
un principe s'il y avait des mesures de
rétorsion des états unis
d'abord je considère que pas à la
hauteur de la région entre la france et
les amériques et les américains ce
serait pour le coup illégal regard des
règles internationales et unilatéral est
ce que nous retirerons dans ce cas la
tariqa fans ont
donc si les états unis veulent aller au
rétorsion
qu'ils le fassent l'europe a dit qu'elle
soutiendra la france dans cette affaire
là
je pense que ce n'est pas une bonne
manière de procéder et je pense que
c'est dommage mais quelque part je dis
on est un état souverain donc quand on
est dans la légalité
la france n'a pas de leçons à recevoir
de quiconque la france elle décide de
mettre un impôt c'est légal au regard
des règles internationales elle fait son
impôt et après si les personnes en face
elle veut le faire dans la mesure de
rétention elle prendra les mesures qui
s'imposent elles en discutera avec ses
partenaires européens et on verra mais
on va pas retirer cette taxe je veux
dire question de crédibilité un moment
nous ne sommes pas je me dis j'étais aux
états unis a levé la semaine dernière
du tennis en très grand pays qui sont
sont nos alliés historiques et ne
serions pas là si elle n'était pas là je
viens n'était pas venu en 1900 1945 ils
sont perdus trois cent mille morts ou
les russes en ont perdu 22 millions mais
les les russes sont le principal fait
les pays qui est le pays qui a payé le
plus gros prix à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et c'est probablement
face et n'avait pas été là ne seront pas
là non plus je ne ne l'oublient pas mais
bon il ya une relation spéciale entre
les américains et les français mais nous
ne sommes pas les partenaires junior des
américains sa main un pays est un grand
pays et qui prend ses décisions de
manière swan
on va parler ingérence
ingérence numérique propagande au sein
de notre territoire propagande houssam
no no no réseau comment on fait pour
faire de la contre propagande comme on
fait pour arrêter les ingérences l'arrêt
aujourd'hui j'ai la communauté qui
m'envoyait un papier sur un groupe
israélien qui prenait contrôle de
certaines pages d'extrême droite pour
exciter la communauté d'extrême droite
américaine sur la communauté musulmane
et je vous en passe et des meilleurs
comme on fait arrêter comment on arrête
ces querelles de chapelle ou ces lobbys
qui font de la structure fing au sein
des populations et surtout en france
comment on fait pour bloquer sa
c'est un sujet qui m'inquiète beaucoup
d'abord parce que en fait notre
démocratie sont assez faibles
parce que notre cadre juridique et
démocratique n'ait pas pensé
pour pour gérer cette situation c'est
une réaction symptomatique attendez je
finis jeu mais je n'ai pas la solution
pour autant et je ne vais pas vers des
solutions plus
je pense que la question se pose parfois
de choisir entre charybde et scylla ce
que je pense au bout déjà principalement
c'est que je pense que nous avons
surestimé historiquement la maturité de
nos démocraties c'est à dire que nous
avons pensé à un moment que l'accès de
tous à la connaissance à toutes les
connaissances et à toutes les
informations aboutirait à une société de
la connaissance c'est faux l'accès de
tous à toutes les informations abouti
pour des raisons psychologiques
psychanalytique sociétal au fait news
c'est à dire que nous préférons les
explications multifactorielle à
multifactorielle si vous lisez les
travaux de gérald bronner par exemple
sont extrêmement intéressants sur
les démocraties des crédules les choses
comme ça les gens préfèrent ou un billet
et serra préfère les explications
simples aux explications complexes ont
des billets d'intentionnalité etc et
donc l'accès de tous à toutes les
connaissances
a abouti à une société de la faillite
news qui n'est pas
forcément
instiguée instigué par des puissances
étrangères
elle profite de cet état de fait mais
elle n'est pas forcément le fait c'était
donc ça c'est la première chose et donc
à long terme à long terme la seule
manière de s'en sortir c'est l'éducation
la long terme la seule manière de s'en
sortir c'est l'éducation il n'ya pas
d'autre manière je suis mais ça prend du
temps mais ça prend du temps mais ça
prend du temps c'est certain temps j'ai
un vendeur il ya un truc qui est très
intéressant parce que je pense que c'est
assez proche de la déradicalisation en
fait la preuve tiko logique était si
proche de la déradicalisation
c'est-à-dire pour comprendre que en fait
cette information cette feuille que muse
elle n'est en fait vous avez un billet
de perception et cetera
c'était très difficile entre eux il ya
un chiffre qui m'a toujours marqué c'est
que dans les sectes et des filles étude
américaine qui ont montré que vu qu'elle
souhaitait de
fait beaucoup d'un site dans l'est dans
les études américaines que montrer
qu'entre le premier jour où un membre
d'une secte un doute et jour où il
quitte la secte en moyen de ses 8 ans
ces huit ans dans des sacs qui prône des
trucs complètement fou
et donc faisant du parti politique ou de
gauche
moi j'ai mis combien de temps j'ai dit
à qui tu es parti socialiste huit ans
[Rires]
c'est drôle
mais
qu'est ce que je disais donc huit ans
donc ça prend du temps l'éducation
entre temps
c'est très compliqué là c'est très
compliqué parce que
je vais je vais prendre un exemple
qui est l'exemple de rts publique qui je
sais faire fera débat
vous regardez une carte et oui je les
regarde régulièrement azpitik sachiez et
chez lui je regarde pas ce que je trouve
ça très intéressant
la manière dont c'est dans ces médias
fonctionnent la plupart du temps ils ne
disent pas des choses fausses
mais ils vont dire un truc comme ça
deux choses de phrases qui sont qui sont
fausses mais je prends cet exemple parce
qu'il est très intéressant ils vont dire
le beau frère de cédric au cégep a deux
beaux frères delphine ou qui a fait la
fondation france lyon glitters le beauf
ils vont dire le beau frère de cédric au
travail pour bouygues points
bouygues a gagné un contrat de 500
millions d'euros avec l'état français
pointent les deux phrases peuvent être
vraies
vous les accoler ce que vous comprenez
c'est que bouygues a gagné un contrat de
500 millions d'euros avec l'état
français parce que le beau frère de
cédric au
travail pour oui parce que c'est beau
fun c'est l'écho les deux phrases sont
vraies légalement vous ne pouvez rien
faire légalement vous ne pouvez rien
faire mais
essayez les canards qui de localiser des
lévriers des canards français qui font
la même chose la seule la seule
différence c'est que pour moi rts pique
nique sont des instruments d' influence
d'une puissance étrangère et donc est ce
que france 24 est donc non je ne pense
pas nous n'avons demande quand il ya un
jour mais un sénateur qui a demandé
l'augmentation des du budget de france
en quatre pour que la france rayonne
mieux à l'étranger donnons pas l'état ne
donne pas de
consignes en tout cas n'influence pas la
ligne éditoriale de france 24 sur
l'a6 qui se passe en russie etc ou en
chine où ou en malaisie vous les mains
de ses rires et donc quelque part je
finis mon idée pourquoi je dis que nos
démocraties sont préparés
c'est légal ces gens sont considérés
comme des journalistes ils sont
journalistes ils ont écart de presse
mais deux ans qui est un journaliste et
journaliste celui qui dit qu'il est
journaliste et journaliste celui qui dit
qu'il est journaliste qui suit 1 50 % de
sa rémunération dans la carte de presse
et des histoires de c'est plutôt bonne
histoire
je croyais économiques fiscales ça n'a
rien à voir gaspard glantz il n'a pas de
carte de presse il est considéré par les
journalistes comme j'en ai pas encore
vus par une partie du risque à retourner
régulièrement les fonds c'est un autre
débat le sujet c'est que j'ai d'ailleurs
de faire son travail
je rentre pas dans ce geste c'est un
autre sujet jusque jeudi juste dire
pourquoi je finis mon idée qu'est ce que
vous en pensez nous sauf qu'en fait ce
qui veut dire ce qui veut dire que un
pays étranger peut délibérément
légalement sans aucun moyen de rétorsion
par par la démocratie venir influé sur
l'élection
parce que il va choisir qui ils avantage
ou un désavantage
mais sortons d'un rts pique nique c'est
comme ça que ça se passe quand on voit
par gagner le jeu fini maintenant une
macro c'est un sujet que je sais si je
continue quand on voit toute la presse
française avec la tête de macron mais
laissez moi finir parce que voter tout
vote homme et tout laisser ma vie
uniquement mal tourné c'est moi finir
donc les un état étranger c'est ça qui
change oui le figaro est plutôt de
droite libération est plutôt de gauche
et historiquement un tel ou tel journal
est plutôt centre droit tel journal oui
les gens ont des opinions oui les gens
peuvent être biaisées où les gens
peuvent elles mal faire leur travail de
journaliste oui il ya une certaine
d'endogamie social dans une partie de
l'establishment français etc
c'est beaucoup de défauts sauf que ce
n'est pas un pays étranger qui choisit à
votre place sous la grande différence
c'est qu'on accepte et je n'ai pas de
solution je n'ai pas de solution parce
qu'à certains égards la solution
pourrait être pire que le problème du
conseil du journaliste c'est ça ce que
vous avez propose là alors je reviens
sur le sujet mais donc
donc donc en fait on accepte quand même
qu'un pays ce qui est ce que les
américains ont accepté et ne savent
toujours pas
c'est que un pays d'être un pays
étranger puisse intervenir dans votre
débat pour influencer votre élection
nationale
et peut-être un jour choisir quel est
votre président c'est ça le résultat
comme ce que les états unis d annoncer
ça le résultat non
alors pour le coup je rappelez vous
d'une option de françois mitterrand g t
ag moi je suis né en 82 donc l'élection
de françois mitterrand c'est en 81
j'avoue que j'ai des souvenirs assez
limité fois en 88 j'ai des souvenirs
assez limitée du débat politique à
l'époque donc je donc c'est quand même
ça le résultat c'est difficile et donc
je veux changer je finis donc je ne mets
jamais alors qu'est ce que j'ai dit sur
le conseil de l'ordre des journalistes
que vous désirez et jeu mais je vais
expliquer ce que j'ai dit et
j'ai dit un mot j'ai un réflexe qui est
touché mais qu'est-ce qui se croit jeune
arthur de style
j'ai dit ça ne peut pas être l'état ça
serait un très mauvais pour un très gros
problème que l'état choisit ce
qui est journaliste ou pas parce que
pour se protéger de l'état justement
parce que je pense n'est pas l'état de
ses tu penses que l'effet que la presse
est encore plus sensible que les
discours de haine et donc ce n'est pas à
l'état de choisir ses par l'état de
choisir est je pense si l'état doit
mettre son doigt dedans c'est très grave
et jeudi néanmoins soit on accepte de ne
rien faire et donc on a cru du coup
qu'un état étranger puisse choisir qui
est notre président notre présidente
parce qu'on dit là mais on peut rien de
tout chez soi la seule solution qui me
paraissait viable
c'était de dire ce qui existe dans
d'autres pays c'est aux journalistes de
décider qui est journaliste c'est
extrêmement violent pour la profession
et sa pose plein de questions je suis
d'accord mais j'ai pas d'autre solution
et c'est donc c'est ce que j'ai dit
c'est ce que j'ai appris un conseil de
l'ordre ça pose plein de questions je ne
sais pas mais mais profondément à titre
personnel c'est un sujet je vois comment
notre démocratie évolué je vois que des
pays étrangers tentent d'influer dans
les démocraties en tout cas ils l'ont
fait aux états unis je sais pas pourquoi
il n'en fera pas en france à un déjeuner
je cherche les moins mauvaise des
solutions ce que j'ai dit qui par
ailleurs a créé la polémique c'est que
j'ai dit et si les journalistes ne font
pas je pense que l'état le fera c'est
pas que je souhaite que l'état le fasse
c'est que je pense qu'à un moment
la réaction d'un gouvernement face à ce
qui est une ingérence étrangère
c'est qu'il va dire j'en sais rien je je
pense qu'il ne faut pas qu'on en arrive
là je pense que c'est très problématique
c'est que je pense que dans un moment de
crise ou en fait est un énorme problème
qui se passe deux jours avant le 2 jours
avant une élection un jour avant une
élection la tentation
d'un gouvernement démocratique et moi je
me battrai toujours pour ça mais je
pense que ça peut être la tentation d'un
gouvernement démocratique c'est de dire
ok c'est moi qui décide je coupe le
signal d'un tel parce que en fait c'est
une ingérence et que donc il va centrer
l'attention des gouvernements dans notre
île peut être de considérer que c'est
une ingérence étrangère que c'est une
agression étrangère c'est quasiment une
attaque et que donc on coupe mais si on
en arrive là c'est terrible c'est
terrible parce que si on met le doigt
dans un truc qui est terrible et donc
j'ai dit c'était plus une un pronostic
que j'ai peur que ça arrive et pas une
menace pour dire si vous le faites pas
je peux le faire je dire
ça n'a aucun sens
donc voila c'était le débat maintenant
qu'on critique sur ce que j'ai dit c'est
de la folie jamais un conseil des
journalistes ok ok
pas de problème alors dites-moi ce que
les gens proposent
pour éviter que des pays étrangers
influent sur notre démocratie qu'on
arrête de venir que ce la justice et que
ce qu'ils font est légal et on va pas
commencer avant d'errer justice de dire
le jugeait que quand on a mis deux
phrases à côté
je reprends l'exemple de scouting parce
que j'ai dit trivialement que c'était de
la merde j'ai personnellement je pense
ça parce qu'ils font du titre put à
cliquer du genre le requin blanc machin
chose à manger le brader puis cliquez
pour venir ok vous regardez rti je
regarde la tête intérêts qu'est ce que
ça donne c'est la propagande à chaque
minute c'est que non mais justement
c'est extra qui s'annonce est malin
c'est extrêmement mal hein déjà il ya
des trucs qui sont de bonne qualité ils
ont des jeux il ya des journalistes qui
sont des journalistes qui ont une
certaine aux médecins qui font des deux
est un moment ils peuvent faire ce que
je vous dis les deux phrases à coller
alors comment on fait pour combattre ça
mais je ne sais pas je viens de vous
répondre c'est que la seule idée qui
m'est venue et je pense qu'ils s'étaient
que ce n'était pas à l'état mais aux
journalistes eux mêmes ne considérait
pas que telle ou telle aux as et que tel
ou tel journal
éventualité mais vraiment quand je dis
ça parce qu'il ya douze jours ni c'est
ma position personnelle parce que c'est
pas il ya un conseil de déontologie qui
a été mis en place par franck riester
qui n'est pas du tout ça c'est à dire
que c'est un truc beaucoup plus
consultatif qui vont pas dire tel
journal thê journal qui vont quitter
leur pose des questions dans la
profession avec certains qu'ils en
pensent
la seule je n'ai pas la réponse
fondamentalement ce que je dis c'est que
ceux qui me disent c'est de la folie
d'un truc ok très bien meilleur dites
moi comment on règle le problème parce
que sinon vous acceptez in fine et qui a
payé choisi ce qui est votre président
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres pays qui font
la même chose en france
que comme vous le décrivez le conseil de
l'ordre alors vraiment baisse conseil 2
0 les pays qui font de l'ingérence en
france outre jojo page d'abord je n'ai
pas d'information qui disent que les
hormis
l'action de rts poteau nicolas je n'ai
pas l'impression qu'ils pensaient que
actions russes je m'en sers première
chose et je n'en sais rien sur d'autres
pays je me base sur ce que je vois de
rts pique nique dont on sait d'où ils
viennent et je vais vous fonde sur ce
qui s'est passé aux états unis qu'en
qu'en france 24 que la life paix est
perçue en afrique comme agence france
propagande ou des choses comme ça c'est
un tort c'est la raison à ce que les
africains ont tort de se méfier ou par
regardant les choses regardons les
choses honnêtement je connais pas j'ai
pas regardé les reportages qui sont
incriminés c'est des choses choquantes
bien regardant les choses joe joe g je
je je ne crois pas parce que je ne crois
pas je pense qu'il ya quand même
fondamentalement
une différence de culture et de entre
des pays démocratiques qui ont plein de
défauts la démocratie française a plein
de défauts mais je pense quand même que
je vais on va arrêter de prendre les
russes prenons le système chinois le
système français on peut pas faire un
parallèle peut pas faire un parallèle
vous avez le droit de critiquer
voire d'insultés n'est pas loin de
menacer nord
le président en france alors de faire ça
fait loin de critiquer l'insulté c'est
pas recommandé non n'est ce pas
recommandée parce que c'est pas si c'est
pas un débat démocratique ça ne sert à
rien vous n'êtes pas loin de menacer
mort parce que ça s'est passé de la loi
mais allez vous amuser à faire ça en
chine et vous verrez la différence je
veux dire et donc donc je ne fais pas
d'égalité entre celles à vous parler de
la chine on va passer à un autre sujet
mais je voudrais par une autre question
est ce qu'on se protège de l'ingérence
technologique chinoise en france par
exemple
si vous avez une amie qui est chinoise
que vous voulez appeler y est est ce que
votre téléphone ou mail prend une photo
de votre tête pour vous mettre dans
leurs fichiers même quand la photo est
prise depuis la france est-ce que vous
avez des choses comme ça je n'y crois
pas trop
il ya une compétition technologique
entre
les différents pays la chine est un des
pays technologiquement les plus
les plus
qui était la plus grande expansion qui
étaient en fait des choses extrêmement
parfois impressionnantes à cet égard je
crois pas qu'ils aient choisi pas
d'informations et je crois pas du tout
qu'est-ce que vous évoquez c'est la
question qui se pose qui est la question
au milieu de deux là
la question du débat actuel c'est le
débat sur la 5g
puisque en fait la question c'est de
dire dans le monde il ya que 4 5
fournisseurs de 5 g aujourd'hui en
europe il y en a que trois ou quatre qui
sont nokia ericsson et huawei des
américains estiment que dans la 5g ils
ont sorti les chinois parce que
en fait la 5g
permet beaucoup de choses et devient une
infrastructure de base de veau
télécommunications est votre système
d'information
la question sur se pose sur ce que font
les européens nous on a dit que on était
extrêmement attentifs au sujet et qu' il
y avait des questions de sécurité qui se
pose est bon on en est là voilà c'est il
faut faire de manière il faut être
extrêmement attentif on n'a pas pour
autant annoncer que on à les bannir les
équipementiers chinois renren est
rotatif il ya des équipements huawei
mais des antennes
france voilà il faut il faut il faut
juste dès lors qu'il ya des questions de
sécurité nationale qui sont en jeu être
attentif
on va parler du comblement du fossé
technologique entre les français il ya
énormément français qui n'ont pas encore
sur internet français compas la kadji
énormément de français avec moi
trafic internet deux des big bags
correct on fait comme on continue de
casser les trottoirs on met de la fibre
on passe par les satellites on fait
comment alors c'est assez marrant parce
que je pense que la manière dont vous
abordez le sujet est assez typique du
débat français je m'explique j'adore le
sujet mais en réalité ces 6 passes mais
non aujourd'hui
en fait on on pense que le problème de
la fracture numérique c'est un problème
de réseau
avec le déploiement de la fibre et le
plan très haut débit le plan mobile
pardon qui est proposée par le
gouvernement je pense que à 99% le
problème sera résolu en 2022 bien
aujourd'hui faut se rendre compte qu'on
connecte à 16000 locaux par jour seize
mille doko par jour le niveau de
développement de la fif la fibre en
france
est inégalée dans le monde entier les
opérateurs n'ont jamais investi autant
d'argent et donc à 99% le problème sera
réglé en 2022 je suis on est assez
optimiste et un plan hyper ambitieux qui
a été mis qui a été doux on a dû forcer
la main des opérateurs pour qu'ils
investissent quelque part qu'on a payé
contre le renouvellement de leur licence
hectares mais bon c'est va
et et sur le mobile donc je en fait pour
ce qui est des tuyaux je suis assez
optimiste je vous dis pas que
au fin fond d'une bergerie dans le la
lozère la zac pour reprendre la zac vous
aurez la fibre mais à 99% le problème
sera réglé en 2022 les gens auront une
très bonne connexion le vrai c'est
pourquoi je dis ça pourquoi je dis ça
c'est que le sujet qui moi m'inquiète
c'est pas le fait d'apporter la
connexion c'est que vous avez 20 % des
français qui estiment n'avoir aucune
compétence numérique et donc tout ce que
je vous raconte là c'est à dire lire
d'intelligence artificielle faut qu'on
soit au niveau de la compétition avec
les chinois il ya les comédiens qu'il
est vrai que c'est très très bien c'est
indispensable c'est vital mais pour les
français c'est inaudible si le numérique
dans leur vie c'est le syndrome est le
facteur de l' exclusion c'est à dire que
c'est c'est à dire qu'en fait on leur
dit bon vous avez des services publics
ont fermé service public là vous allez
aller sur internet tout va bien tout va
bien bon vous authentifier avec votre
titre
mais le ce serait un facteur de
simplicité jeu en l'espèce vous allez
sur internet tout va bien mais les gens
il y en a 13 union qui savent pas se
servir d'internet donc quand vous vous
leur dites battue va faire ta
déclaration d'impôts de revenus en ligne
mais c'est d'une violence sociale un
signe c'est d'une violence sociale
incident pire c'est ya plus de il ya
plus de confirmer trésorerie à l'heure
d'hiver en ligne c'est très bien si on a
mis on a déployé les trucs pour qu'ils
sachent se servir de ce dossier si vous
n'avez pas fait c'est terrible et
deuxième chose parfois ils savent très
bien servir de des outils en ligne mais
c'est juste qu'ils marchent pas
c'est juste que les sites internet n'ont
pas forcément été conçu pour tout le
monde un peu comme le truc de et
pilonnés donc je vous prends un exemple
et
moi je m'appelle cedrico une lettre donc
les gens connaissent un peu internet
savent que c'est une galère parce que le
nombre de formulaires qui demandent de
l'aide minimum c'est un truc de dingue
donc quand je prends le train je
m'appelle cédric aux eaux quand je
prends l'avion je m'appelle cédric aux
eaux dans certains sites je m'appelle
cédric aux eaux denses à dorval cedrico
je me débrouille et je viens c'était une
issue qui nous
mêmes les américains c'est en fait sur
les avions ce qui est drôle c'est que
c'est ça vient d'une nomenclature iata
donc
d'accords internationaux et donc en fait
mais nous américains savent que une
lettre ça passe pas donc je passe
j'entre aux états unis au plan je
reviens pourquoi c'est un truc de dingue
au delà du côté un peu drôle c'est que
de plus en plus les uns les
administrations on développe des
interconnexions c'est à dire qu'il ya un
truc qui est insupportable dans les
démarches admiratif c'est qu'on leur
demande des papiers que les autres
administrations ont typiquement votre
revenu fiscal votre carte d'identité ou
votre attestation de domicile peut pas
domicile mais de crèches il ya une
aberration parce que c'est des papiers
que d'autres administrations ont
concours demande en cinq exemplaires
alors et donc on fait de plus en plus de
truc c'est qu'on interconnecte les trucs
pour que quand vous faites une démarche
si on a déjà des informations qui sont
disponibles on voulait leur demande pas
parce que à chaque fois qu'on vous
demande un papier vous perdez des gens
parce que les gens ne sont pas à l'aise
avec les outils d'un peu beaucoup de
gens ne sont pas à l'aise avec les
outils d'internet un français sur cinq
est je le rappelle donc on développe ça
sauf que si tu vois je m'appelle cédric
peau dans une administration assedic ou
dans l'autre à sa bug et donc ça marche
pas
sauf que les rares titres qui sont
obligés eux savent pas réglé le problème
est donc vous vous retrouvez dans un
truc kafkaïen
et donc je dis ça pourquoi tu dis ça
parce que en fait ce qu'on doit changer
au delà des tuyaux c'est que il faut
penser
usagers or c'est pas historiquement une
manière dont l'administration réfléchit
ça va jusqu'à remettre des numéros de
téléphone parce que tout le monde
connaît le truc de je suis sûr sur une
démarche ça marche pas je suis dans un
truc qui me bloque il n'ya pas numéro de
téléphone n'est pas dans la semaine et
donc quelque part la question je sais
pour ça je pense que la question de la
fracture numérique la question de
comment on forme les 13 millions de
personnes enfin autonomise les traits en
fait tiendra à moitié notons ici vous
pouvez les autonomiser les six ou sept
millions de français qui peut être
autonomiser comment on fait en sorte que
les ceux qui ne peuvent pas être nommé
il est des solutions à côté de chez eux
et qu'ils soient pas complètement exclue
il faut dans l'est dans les comptes
rendus du grand débat donc après les
jets des jeunes a fait le grand débat et
16 me de 18 ans et plus réunions
physiques il n'y a pas une réunion
physique quasiment où les français ne
parle pas du numérique comme un facteur
d'exclusion pour le secrétaire d'état au
numérique c'est terrible parce que c'est
bien sûr des opportunités mais en fait
si on veut faire en sorte qu'on continue
à faire société on doit résoudre ce
problème donc c'est pour moi c'est au
delà de la french touch au delà de
l'agression negafa c'est peut-être le
vrai sujet de mon gros sujet de 2020
c'est la fracture numérique c'est faux
je vais pas rentrer dans le débat mais
c'est faux maîtres des endroits dont les
maisons france service où les gens ont
fait à leur place faux faux que partout
en france et des médiations numérique où
on autonomise les gens il faut qu'on
repense nos sites internet en les
pensant à pour tout le monde autre chose
c'est quand un site internet ne marche
pas un stade ça peut être génial quand
vous êtes quand vous êtes mal voyants
mais si c'est pas prévu pour les
malvoyants
et donc en fait c'est le message que
l'état envoie à des citoyens c'est tu
n'es pas important pour moi j'ai une
question concernant le fait que bercy
puisse aspirer les données des réseaux
sociaux pour
aller chercher des informations c'est
bien c'est pas bien le fait que bercy
puissent avoir accès je pense ainsi
pouvoir de contrôler et il ya la cnil
qui a fait un certain nombre de
recommandations il faut qu'ils soient
contrôlés
je pense que dès lors que c'est contrôlé
et supervisé et qu'il ya un certain
nombre de garde-fous ça ne me gêne pas
ça ne me gêne pas parce que les mêmes
qui nous disent
ccc vous êtes des fous demain c'est pas
pour aller chercher madame michu aux
messieurs mais chut c'est notamment
quand vous dites je suis pas résident
fiscal français et qu'en fait on se rend
compte que vous poster des photos sur
instagram tous les tous les deux vous et
tout en france mais ça c'est du batik ce
quand je prends l'exemple du résident
fiscal c'est quand je prends ces
métadonnées joie qui selon gatel bord
arrêtez de tout chez micro quand je vois
qui se borne à telle antenne et que
éculés hum ça indique que son téléphone
portable est en france c'est une chose
comme ça c'est des surveillances ah non
je ne pense pas que ça jusqu'au
bernachon téléphone portable c'est à
dire quand on regarde le pour moi
l'expérimentation aller sur les réseaux
sociaux et ça va pas jusqu au bornage
leur a pas demandé des données
opérateurs de donner truc comme ça c'est
assez limité d'ailleurs je pense que
c'est quand qu'on serait pas le faire
donc dans le fond votre question c'est
est-ce que le fait que bercy que le
contrôle fiscal puisse s'appuyer sur des
données de réseaux sociaux qui sont des
données dont une partie est considérée
public
tout sous contrôle de garde-fous
rétablir un certain nombre d'aberrations
je dis que je suis je suis favorable
mais parce que je crois aux institutions
et encore je pense que quand on dit on
mettre des garde-fous moi je crois au
regard de fou c'est à dire je pense que
les gens contrôler que les gens font pas
n'importe quoi question internet comment
il articule le développement du
numérique et la transition énergétique
c'est un sujet sur lequel
je me pose beaucoup de questions et où
les les
les données scientifiques sont assez
inégales c'est à dire que d'un côté la
transition énergétique n'est pas
possible sans le numérique pour une
raison simple c'est que si vous passez
d'un système qui fonctionne aujourd'hui
où en gros il centrale alimente une
une ville à un système qui sera le
l'énergie de demain hyper décentralisée
où ce sont les voitures électriques qui
recrache feront leur électricité la nuit
sacha il y aura des petites des petites
centrales y aura des gens qui produiront
avec des panneaux solaires il ya des
gens qui produire avec des mines
éoliennes et tout ça devrait
s'équilibrer dans le réseau ça ne marche
pas son numérique si avec tout ça soit
numérisé pour que avec de l'intelligence
artificielle et c'est tout ça
s'équilibre savez la transition
énergique n'est pas possible ça pas de
numérique première chose deuxième chose
smart grid lesparre de rites exactement
j'essaye d'éviter les longues listes
mais c'est lesparre des exactement la
deuxième chose c'est que
des usages sont permis par le numérique
le télétravail etc qui sont profondément
et écologique même le commerce vous
prenez les commerces qui et qui souvent
dans le visa j'ai regardé des études
le bilan écologique de l'e-commerce il
est très controversée c'est pas du tout
sûr que ce soit de négatif c'est à dire
que dans le modèle ou en fait vous avez
une camionnette remplie à ras bord qui
livre en pleine journée sans bouchons
selon un chemin à optimiser ses colis
plutôt que tout le monde prend sa
voiture pour aller faire ses courses
allauch en deux
de périphériques un fou au carrefour de
périphérie
honnêtement certaines études montrent
que les commerces et plus respectueux de
20 produits moins de gaz à effet de
serre donc la question se pose et
ensuite vous avez dernièrement les deux
les deux questions qui sont
problématiques c'est à dire les terres
rares et le recyclage des iphone et puis
vous avez les gens qui regardent des
vidéos notamment des vidéos enfin tous
types de vidéos va dire et en vidéos
peuvent être basse définition exactement
et et il faut se rendre compte que quand
vous regardez une vidéo alors il ya
plein d'études franchement leur validité
scientifique j'ai du mal à l'estimé
qu'ils que quand vous regardez une vidéo
d'une demi heure c'est comme une ampoule
de 26 watts allumée pendant bon ok quand
vous regardez une vidéo c'est pas
innocent ça consiste à fsa fait tourner
en data centers ça fait tourner des
calculateurs ça chauffe non seulement ça
chauffe non plus vous produire de
l'électricité pour faire tourner et donc
on estime que aujourd'hui le numérique
en termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre brut c'est-à-dire sans la
plus polluante que l'industrie
aéronautique
est donc là je pense qu'il ya des choses
à faire c'est à dire que pour les data
center qui sont en france nous on met
des doors une énorme en terme de
récupération de chaleur dans le 13ème
arrondissement de paris vous avez un
datacenter qui chauffe une piscine il
faut aller vers ça
mais la vérité c'est que la plupart des
data center ils sont pas en france donc
la plupart des andes des centres de
données sur lequel tourne les vidéos que
les français regardent ne sont pas en
france ils sont dans les pays
limitrophes en asie aux états unis et
donc là je pense qu'il ya une question
d'éducation également à la fois sur
l'utilisation des smartphones et
fassions le renouvellement des
smartphones et sur les vidéos où il faut
que les gens soient conscients tout
comme quand il laisse une lumière
allumée bassin concernant excité que
quand ils regardent des vidéos quand ils
font du binge drinking ou encore parce
que une partie des vidéos qu'on regarde
je veux inclus dans la liste indique qu
en ce moment comme séville g j'ai
commencé faoud à dents pendant qu'on
allait mon aller retour aux états unis
donc quand vous regardez des vidéos mais
en fait le problème c'est pas quand vous
regardez fao d'art le problème c'est que
en fait bon nombre des vidéos vous
regardez c'est que vous scrollé sur
votre fil twitter ou sur votre fil
facebook et des vidéos qui se déclenche
parfois des pubs parfois un peu débile
parfois qui n'ont qu'un intérêt limité
ça ça pollue et du timide utilité
marginale que ça pour votre vie pour
votre confort que l'essence est limité
donc c'est sur ça qu'il faut se
maîtriser mais je pense qu'il ya un gros
sujet de l'éducation et la formation
tout comme un moment personne savait que
jeté sa cigarette par terre jetée sans
gobelet par terre ou laisser la lumière
ça pose des problèmes ça je pense qu'il
faut les mois je le dis autant que je
peux mais par contre je jusqu'au lycée
que
le ce serait une erreur par l'air de
penser que le bilan énergétique totale
du numérique est négatif je pense qu'il
est une fine est positif mais ça ne
m'empêche pas qu'ils aient des problèmes
on arrive bientôt à la fin je vais je
vais vous poser encore deux trois quatre
questions vous voyez la france dans cinq
ans ou est-ce que la crise sociale va
s'apaiser est ce que l'économie
française va enfin va tenir le choc est
ce que vous voyez une décroissance
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
décroissance est-ce que vous pensez que
la france va devenir un pays touristes
pour chinois est ce que vous pensez
qu'on est cuit ou est ce qu'on n'est pas
cuit est ce que vous êtes confiant dans
l'avenir page plutôt optimiste donc oui
je suis confiant tu confirmes parce
qu'on a les cerveaux vraiment je reviens
à ce que je disais tout à l'heure on a
les cerveaux enfin en fout qu'ils
restent ici il faut qu'on dise et du
développent leur boîte ici et faut
qu'ils en font qu'on investisse ici
dans les faits je vais pas vous faire
l'aller c'est pas de lieux saints ne pas
vous faire la peine et les
la vente la vente du gouvernement mais
dans les faits les indicateurs
économiques sont meilleures qu'il ya
deux ans d'ailleurs on a recréé on a
recréé quand même depuis 2007 cinq cent
mille emplois et vient en aide à quelque
500 millions de personnes qui ont trouvé
de l'emploi
l'investissement des entreprises n'a
jamais été aussi haut depuis dix ans le
moral des entreprises n'a jamais été
aussi haut depuis dix ans on a
je prends la l'économie du numérique
puisque tu faisais que le sujet c'est de
créer l'écosystème français vient de
dépasser l'écosystème allemand on a
doublé taille en deux ans donc je dis
pas que tout va bien il reste encore
plein de problèmes et de la tension
sociale montre que les gens ne sont pas
contents mais ça va mieux donc je suis
plutôt optimiste ce que ce que
je ne sois pas nous ne sommes pas
condamnés à être un pays de tourisme
pour les taux et chinois et je pense que
il ya
un instinct français il ya une
spécificité française et un panache
français qui fait qu' on va réussir j'en
suis persuadé profondément
et je pense qu'on a les atouts pour le
faire
après on a un pays qui est profondément
déchiré c'est à dire que que je pense
que l'histoire que ce pays se raconte
la france sait plus quelle histoire nous
nous racontons et je pense que c'est
très violent
parce que parce que historiquement les
français on pensait qu'ils avaient un
message pour le monde et que et je pense
que là la difficulté économique des
vingt trente dernières années a
profondément heurté les français il ya
des tensions sociales qui ne sont pas
l'apanage des français c'est à dire que
les tensions sociales
quelque part ce qui a causé la révolte
des gilet jaune
il ya des éléments très français mais
entre l'élection de donald trump le bras
exit la montée des extrêmes en bray au
brésil au chili lé pas au chili au
brésil il faut des ruchers non c'est il
ya il ya une tension avec les classes
moyennes des classes moyennes classe
moyenne voilà qui est un phénomène
occidental où les classes moyennes sont
mises sous pression pas à la fois la
mondialisation qui fait qu'elles sont
mis sous pression salariale
et des transformations qui vient de les
percuter directement comme
la hure économie
l'intelligence artificielle les robots
l'automatisation du travail et qui fait
que
celle ci il ya une part des français qui
dit mais ce monde ne me va pas ce monde
ne me va pas et ça s'exprime contre le
gouvernement ce qui est naturel mais
c'est d'abord ce n'est pas que français
et est ensuite si vous me demandez
quelles sont les solutions je pense que
je vais dire un truc qui n'est pas
d'alternative dire que nous devons le
problème de la france c'est qu'elle ne
produit pas assez elle redistribuer de
l'argent qu'elle ne produit pas puisque
on creuse la dette chaque année on est
un pays en faillite on dirait fillon non
ce n'est pas un pays en faillite mais
mais on a un pays qu à 100% de dette et
donc on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut
donc le priorité c'est de produire plus
et d'être plus compétitif la priorité
c'est sartre au 18 mai produire plus
écologiquement temps alors pour vieira
la décroissance moi je ne
crois pas décroissance je ne crois pas
je sens que le parc ou un jeu c'est une
non moi je suis pas le plus le plus
caricatural des chaussées il ya alors il
ya plus en plus d' hec qui sont en
politique mais en général mes copains
ils font plutôt enfin ceux qui étaient
avec moi là ils font plutôt du marketing
la finance ils ont créé leur boîte et
gagnent beaucoup plus d'argent que moi
donc j'ai aussi chouette plus
ça dépend moi je gagne 1000 euros net
par mois je pense que je dois être
pas loin dans mes amis
deux premiers de la chaussée quoi je
vais lui qui doit être dans en tout cas
dans la moitié inférieure est dans la
moitié inférieure pas ça peut partir
très très bien et là qui ont créé leur
boîte qui ont gagné plusieurs millions
donc si je voulais gagner l'argent
n'aurait pas fait ça
je sais plus où est ce que j'en étais du
coup d'une croissance décroissance bon
en fait je pense que
c'est théoriquement bien sur le papier
mais pense que la décroissance c'est la
guerre je pense que la décroissance et
là je pense que une société on doit tout
faire pour verdir la manière dont notre
économie fonctionne pour être pour
éviter un arrêté certaines d'un gris etc
et je pense que socialement ce n'est pas
possible c'est à dire que vendre aux
gens que on va faire mieux
mais moi
et qu'ils gagnent enfin que je pense
qu'on ne sait pas résoudre sa société ne
savent pas résoudre ça c'est surtout le
système financier qui s'est par exemple
si on a une décroissance sur le système
financier tous castellon et je pense que
le système financier
est encore une fois je n'ai pas
d'intérêts dedans
je pense que le système financier delà
des dérives et que de dire je suis
contre le système financier c'est qu'à
venir je suis contre les routes parce
qu'ils acceptent en question d'être
contre s'il six témoins financier
ralenti qu'est ce qui se passe mais je
pense qu'il ne peut pas arrêter que
créer de la richesse
c est que ça financer c'est une question
de laisser financiers ce sont les routes
et des ponts la question c'est notre
société qui est dessus elle ne peut pas
arrêter de créer de la richesse pour les
sanctions les fonds de retraite ça c'est
les routes et les ponts et les routes et
les ponts cetc on a décidé d'avoir une
les fonds de pension
barils
tout comme les fonds de pension les
américains ils ont décidé de faire de la
retraite par capitalisation
démocratiquement personne n'a jamais
forcé ya jamais un mec qui est dit ils
veulent pas de la retraite par
répartition vous regardez son âge
l'américain n'est même pas de la
retraite par répartition
on vous fait de sac avec des fonds comme
il faut bien donner votre argent à
quelqu'un et comme il ya de l'inflation
faut bien quelqu'un il le place pour que
cet argent grossistes question jusque là
rien remarqué que ton style des taux
négatifs une question de masse qatar
je pense que ça met sous tension
c'est ça met sous tension des
établissements financiers que c'est un
problème
mais
je suis pas économiste mais je comprends
que inutile pour être là pour longtemps
et donc ça ça pose des problèmes en
termes de politiques macro économiques
parce que
ça repose des questions sur comment vous
gérez
les politiques monétaires des banques
centrales ça remet les questions de
politique budgétaire ou de politique
d'investissement je lisais un article de
kenneth rogoff là dans une tribune de
kenneth rogoff dans le monde qui dit et
que qu'il ya une partie qui dit que ça
veut dire qu'on peut refaire beaucoup
plus de dette et lui dit mais non je ne
pense pas
je pense que le risque des taux négatifs
c'est justement qu'on pense que du coup
on peut faire beaucoup plus de dettes et
que le lavage est ouverte alors que je
pense qu'au bout du bout vous êtes
toujours rattrapé par la réalité des
choses
est que l'histoire de la crise de 2008
c'est une cruelle histoire de dette
privée titrisés d'accessoires de
surendettement privé
et que
qu'on considère que l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux
peut du coup enfin qu' il faudrait pas
que la prochaine crise soit une crise de
dette publique ce serait 100 fois pire
vous voyez des choses à aborder qu'on va
pas aborder à vous de vous poser les
deux dernières questions je pensais
qu'on parlait de la parleriez de
l'histoire de la lettre lutte contre la
haine en ligne parce que oui exact alors
la loi mais du coup on est sûr vu qu'on
est à la fin au bond le temps aussi les
techniciens sung y
aller un bout un mot sur la lay line en
ligne danois sur la ligne alors la
quadrature vous a bien changé sur la cca
des sujets sur lesquels ils sont pas
d'accord avec moi pourquoi si on pas
d'accord est ce que vous allez chercher
à les comprendre mais je comprends très
bien mais je pense que nous ne sommes
pas en fait nous pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas d'accord alors je viens sur le débat
il ya aujourd'hui une
1,1 des faits un déferlement de haine
henry je pense qu'on peut dire ça et je
pense que vous en avez été victime je
pense que beaucoup de français ont été
victimes je pense qu'il est assez rare
que quelqu'un ne connaissent pas soit un
gamin soit quelqu'un de son entourage
qui a été harcelé en ligne etc je pense
que nous avons un problème de santé
publique et
est donc la question c'est que le rôle
quand même de l'état selon moi c'est de
protéger ses citoyens et après je vais
venir venir solution est donc vous n'en
voulez pas vous n'insultez pas vous nous
menacez pas de mort quelqu'un dans la
rue
ctac qui vous parce que les tabous enfin
peu ta protège ses citoyens travers
le ce que ce que nous nous disons c'est
que le problème qui est aujourd'hui
celui de la nba c'est un problème de
viralité tampon et de masse c'est dire
qu'il ya une telle masse de contenus
haineux que la justice ne sait pas gérer
ça la justice ne sait pas gérer ça je
prends l'exemple de christchurch la
vidéo du massacre de christchurch dont
du massacre qui s'est passé dans une
mosquée en nouvelle-zélande a été retiré
par facebook un million cinq cent mille
fois
dans les 24 heures qui ont suivi les jce
d'abord il faudrait arriver à trouver
tous les gens qui l'ont recruté parce
que c'est quand même légalement
interdite c'est quand même de l'apologie
de la violence voilà
et puis la justice s'est pas passé un
million cinq cent mille fois en 24
heures ou même en un mois donc ce que ce
que
nous nous disons c'est que
ya alors il ya eu plusieurs approches du
sujet et les allemands qui ont passé une
loi qui dit
n'importe quel contenu
manifestement illégal qui arrive en
ligne
facebook enfin qui n'est pas retirée par
les plateformes les plateformes en sont
responsables et elle paye on his
milliers d'euros pour chaque contenu
et donc les plateformes disent ok très
bien
sûr on sur bloc c'est à dire que dès
qu'on a un doute on retire ce qui amène
à retirer des contenus illégaux bien sûr
mais demain des caricatures de mende et
des propos d'un homme politique quand
marine le pen diffusé une vidéo de
l'état islamique
ça fait pas plaisir je pensais que pas
une bonne idée
mais quelque part je pensais pas à
facebook de retirer la vidéo
ch parce que c'est à la justice de juger
donc donc c'est ça c'est la loi mais
nous ce que notre loi elle dit les
bourses australienne je ne sais plus
c'est plus long mais je prends cet
exemple là parce que c'est on peut dire
une vidéo de l'état islamique c'est
illégal donc en fait vous retirer quand
c'est un an un responsable politique qui
la truite en disant voilà c'est ça
l'état islamique si vous vous m'insultez
vous menacer de mort ma mère
je veux bien vous insultez mes pensées
non c'est illégal vont menacer de mort
mais dans vos bras saisissent pas
simplement sur internet comment il
s'appelle votre maman je ne dis pas
voulu pas juste le bon jour
donc
c'était légal par contre si moi j'écris
monsieur singer view a menacé de mort
m'a dit ta ta ta je trouve que c'est
intolérable je vais laisser passer pas
illégal parce que mais mais mais mais
mais enfin est-ce que c'est illégal
voilà donc la question donc le problème
du fait de prendre un petit plus là non
mais c'est qu'en fait je
refuse de juger ce qui est légal n'est
pas légal et donc si les plateformes on
leur dit dès qu'il ya un doute mais si
jamais tu laisses passer quelque chose
qui est illégal
et bien on va te sanctionné elles vont
tous retirés c'est ce qu'elles font en
allemagne non ce qu'on a mis dans la loi
c'est qu'on dit
les plateformes doivent se doter d des
moyens technologiques
réguler d'ailleurs ni au bon niveau
technologique et humain pardon est donc
en fait on leur met une obligation de
moyens et on leur dit si elles ne font
elles ne sont pas à cette obligation de
moyens si elle ne répondait ne sont pas
au bon niveau de régulation alors le
régulateur pour à les sanctionner donc
en gros on dit vous devez vous doter des
moyens technologiques et humains pour
lutter contre la haine en ligne de
manière efficace en moins de 24 heures
donc le principe c'est vous devez
retirer un commentaire les commentaires
haineux au moins de 24 heures nous
savons très bien que vous ne retirez pas
tous les commentaires haineux parce que
ce n'est pas possible et que il ya des
choses qui font que c'est litigieux donc
vous ne réussirez pas par contre on aura
un régulateur en l'occurrence le csa qui
viendra juger y compris sur pièces et
sur place que vous faites vos meilleurs
efforts
apportés dans des interférences et donc
en fait mon porte a fait notre force
pardon et donc on pose cette obligation
de moyens cette obligation de 2
de protection on dit
il faut en fait vérifier que les
plateformes font tout ce qu'elles
peuvent mais nous n'avons pas d'autres
moyens de le faire c'est à dire que
c'est pas à l'état qui va vérifier
toutes les choses c'est assez symétrique
au système bancaire c'est à dire que
pour les virements frauduleux
c'est pas l'état qui vérifie que les sûr
quand vous faites des virements sont des
virements frauduleux ou pas
c'est votre banque n'est pas responsable
de tous les deux tout les virements
frauduleux qui sont faits d'un compte de
la bnp ou d'un compte du crédit agricole
par contre les banques sont responsables
d'avoir un système de contrôle interne
qui est au niveau de l'enjeu et il ya un
régulateur public qui vérifie qu elles
ont un système de contrôle interne au
niveau de l'enjeu et c'est comme ça on
fait le parallèle avec 7
avec cette société générale mais il y
aura toujours des abus
il y aura des téléphones qui sonnent
et un avion il son téléphone samedi
[Musique]
bon il y aura toujours des abus mais on
peut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain il faut continuellement adapter les
régulations et c'est toujours les
boucliers régulation bancaire a fait son
travail mais la régulation prudentielle
h danse et l'art en mai mais si vous
avez quoi comme autre solution on
supprime les manques
oui et il faut sans cesse mettre à jour
la régulation à l'agression court
toujours vers les abus oui et c'est ça
la vie démocratique c'est ça la vie
d'une économie donc donc qu'est-ce que
je reviens au sujet de la banque et de
la loi bien alors nous on dit ça je
pense que là là là
et on pense que c'est la seule manière
d'avoir un truc qui permet de trouver la
ligne de crête je sais que là entre
liberté d'expression et protection
la quadrature quelque part est opposé
à tout filtrage des contenus quels
qu'ils soient en disant filtrage des
contenus égale début de surveillance
le problème de sa dette ou encore le
problème de ça c'est ça que je touche
parle du résultat
mais
les citoyens ce qu'ils demandent à
l'état particulièrement c'est d'avoir la
protection et donc si l'état notamment
les sociétés démocratiques n'est pas
capable de protéger ses citoyens et de
trouver des compromis qui leur assure un
minimum de protection mais alors à quoi
il sert
je pense que dans la philosophie de la
croix nature il ya une philosophie assez
libertaire est assez alors eux ils
disent non la solution c'est
l'interopérabilité et donc c'est de dire
qu' il faut faire en sorte que si vous
avez un compte sur facebook vous posiez
les surmas tout sur twitter pour y aller
sur mastodonte conserver vos amis est en
fait les gens voteront avec leurs pieds
d'abord je pense ça pose une question
principe yale je pense que ça veut dire
qu'on règle par le marché quelque part
en fluidifiant le marché un problème
principal quand même et quand vous
parler avec des gens ils ne
réfléchissent pas comme ça nous disent
mais mettez l'état
si je suis en danger sur facebook mais
règlent le problème sur facebook ne me
demande pas d'aller sur mastodonte ou
sur machin bragin c'est donc ton boulot
c'est quand même de me protéger première
chose
et deuxième chose je pense que la
réflexion par l'interopérabilité je
pense que l'interopérabilité
est un outil qui peut être essentiel
dans le cadre de la fusion sur l'anti
trust mais je pense que la réflexion sur
le solutionner de la preuve la
problématique de l'aisne dans l'est par
l'interopérabilité c'est une solution
pardon de deux geeks ou de
métropolitains c'est à dire que c'est
les gens qui
savent gérer tous ces outils qui sont
hyper agile moi quand je suis pas
content de delhi vers où je vais sur
hubert ride ce que ma mère
elle un compte facebook et enfin
d'ailleurs là pas de compte facebook
mais quand elle utilise un truc elle
utilise un truc et on les dit demain
fois les surmas tél si jamais elle se
mettait à compte créer un compte
facebook déjà ça serait la galère mais
si on me dit va sur mastodonte mais elle
est incapable de le faire donc je pense
qu'il faut réfléchir avec la société
qu'on a avec les gens qu'on a donc il
faut trouver des compromis qui sont
toujours des compromis qui sont
insatisfaits peuvent être satisfaisant
mais en tout cas moi je pense que la
première responsabilité c'est de faire
en sorte qu'ils aient un peu moins de
rennes en ligne et on trouve une
solution qu'on estime différente de la
loi allemande après on peut avoir des
débats il y aura problème en quelques
petites modifications au sénat a donc
jamais mais c'est pour ça que je dis
qu'il faut réfléchir au résultat c'est
que la réflexion qui veut que
principalement faut surtout pas de aucun
filtrage des contenus parce que c'est le
début de la surveillance est alors
d'accord mais ok alors à la fin les gens
ils se diront que l'état ne sert à rien
et que donc ils vont faire autre chose
mais dans le fond je pense que le
le débat il est toujours ça c'est ce
contrat aux institutions pas donc ça si
c'est une solution symptomatique le fait
que l'augmentation de la haine que les
tensions sociales que l'augmentation dès
violences aux personnes l'augmentation
des dégradations et le fait que la haine
se traduisent en ligne et j'en passe et
des meilleurs est ce qu'il n'ya pas des
solutions proactives où on va dire plus
en amont pour je vais pas dire d'étendre
les gens ou leur faire une faire une
psychothérapie mais mais ne pas avoir
tout le temps que des mesures
symptomatique symptomatique
symptomatique si l'aed se matérialisent
vous avez raison mais il ya une question
de temporalité c'est que la haine en
ligne jédir les gamins qui sont harcelés
qui parfois termine vers suicider
les journalistes des hommes politiques
vous les français qui prennent des
médailles d'or c'est maintenant j'ai à
dire bien sûr que le sujet de fond c'est
l'éducation ces libérations de la
société etc et c'est que nous sommes
arrivés dans une dans une acceptation de
la violence dans la société
qui est folle qui est folle et qui fait
que mais je pense que les techniciens
qui refusent de venir tourner
l'interview parce que je suis mise les
manuels mâcon fait partie de ces
violences certes je pense qu'on est on
est on est arrivé dans une société qui
refuse l'altérité qui refuse que
quelqu'un puisse légitimement penser
différemment refuse que les gens
puissent légitimement sans aucun conflit
personnel penser penser différemment on
refuse ça c'est à dire que si vous êtes
je prends un exemple
notre société si vous êtes ultra
libérale si vous êtes
communiste c'est forcément parce que
vous devez les intérêts personnels à le
faire mais pas du tout mais moi je le
récuse ça je veux dire jean luc
mélenchon c'est un des politiciens les
plus riches de france il a il défend une
autre style riche tout ça non un
patrimoine qui est en dessous du million
d'euros la dent je pense qui est au
dessus de 2 millions emmanuel macron et
tout son fric qu'il a gagné quand il a
été un travail et dans les maquis les
génisses nous
a aussi de l'argent est ce que je veux
dire c'est que quelque part vous allez
trouver logique emmanuel macron et
défendre des dépositions des positions
plutôt libérales
moi j'ai aucun problème pour que jean
luc mélenchon alors que c'est quelqu'un
qui aime l'argent jean jaurès et léon
blum étaient des gens qui avaient
beaucoup d'argent c'est des grands
bourgeois mais ils ont le droit de
défendre leurs options légitimement moi
j'ai le droit d'avoir de défendre la vie
que en fait il faut baisser la taxation
sans que les gens m'accusent que de
faire parce que c'est mes amis non je
pense que c'est la bonne solution pour
la france et je ne fais pas je pense
qu'il ya des gens j'aime les gens
cohérents et donc je pense que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration je peux accepter
que des gens une option différente c'est
à dire si je pensais que le trotskisme
était la meilleure manière d'améliorer
la société mais je serais trop triste
moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour un
type comme daniel bensaïd je trouve que
ces gens sont des gens cohérents
mais je peux accepter que des gens
voient la vision de la ville différente
moi je pense je peux accepter que des
gens défendent la sur taxation des
riches et je ne pense pas que ils le
font parce qu'ils sont jaloux je pense
qu'ils le font parce qu'ils pensent que
c'est la meilleure solution mais dans ce
cas là qu'on me laisse penser ce que je
pense en bon en m'accordant le crédit
jusqu'à ce que l'un vers soi ou soit
prouvé que je le fais parce que je pense
que la meilleure solution pour la france
je pense qu'en fait on est venu où cette
discussion ne peut plus avoir lieu et
donc je pense que la salade tensions
dans la société est extrêmement forte ce
qu'on peut plus discuter avec des gens
qui pensent différemment je pense qu'on
accepte difficilement
comme on accepte de plus en plus
difficilement
l'altérité de la pensée en tout cas
qu'on estime que si l'autre pense
différemment c'est qu'il a un intérêt
personnel pour le faire alors que
l'autre ils posent problème en
différemment parce qu'ils pensent que
vous avez un solution et là on peut
avoir un débat mais si vous pensez qu'en
fait il un intérêt personnel pour le
faire et que donc c'est pas un problème
de propos mais c'est un problème
d'essence mais dans ce cas là je pense
que l'aide donc je reviens à mon propos
ça c'est un énorme sujet je n'ai pas
forcément la solution je pense que
beaucoup de choses et dans l'éducation
mais en tout cas il ya un problème
d'urgence c'est-à-dire que s'y résoudre
ce problème prendra des années et on
voit la dynamique qui a été celle des
pays développés avec ce basculement dans
l'inquiétude et la défiance s'est pas
fait du jour au lendemain la dynamique
inverse très difficile prendrait des
années en attendant il ya des gens qui
souffrent sur internet qui se font
insulter
c'est ça ça doit être on peut pas dire
ok je vois bien tsi bérard seul et
t'inquiète on va résoudre le problème de
la société on va expliquer à tous les
gamins que vlad en 15 ans tu ne sais
plus si bernard seux les jeux comment il
sera suicide avant donc
quand vous êtes responsable politique
s'il ya des décisions à prendre des
décisions à prendre parfois faire des
compromis donc on arrive à la fin de
notre interview et on demande de la
première question ses conseillers trois
bouquins notre communauté
et ensuite cdc un conseil pour les
jeunes générations quelque chose
d'impérissables alors
conseillé trois bouquins
j'ai commencé par le bouquin qui le
roman qui moi le mal le plus bouleversé
dans les dernières années c'est l'art de
perdre d'alice zeniter
je pense qu'il faut lire l'art de perdre
des listes unitaires c'est l'histoire
allez-y terre c'est une
immigrés de deuxième génération
d'origine algérienne dans le grand dont
le père le grand-père s'agit d'oublier
dont le père a été acquis dans le grand
père a été requis et l'art de perdre ses
les harkis et c'est
l'art de perdre d'alice zeniter pour moi
c'est l'histoire de la france c'est
l'histoire de la france et est et alice
zeniter en étant algérienne a écrit sur
son grand père algérien le bouquin que
j'adorerais écrire sur ma grand mère
coréenne et en étant à moitié coréen je
considère que ce qu'elle est enfin que
ce qu'elle a écrit que mon histoire et
je donc je recommande ce roman
enfin c'est
pour moi un roman extérieur c'est
peut-être alors j'ai pas lu les romans
de la rentrée littéraire de cette
rentrée mais c'était le roman de l'année
un deuxième bouquin
je le garde restez sur les romances et
vite l'homme qui aimait les chiens de
leonardo padura sur l'histoire croisée
de 30 ce qui guide son assassin
exceptionnel exceptionnel aussi et un
troisième roman
si les gens aiment
plus de manière un peu moins
intellectuel la griffe du chien de don
winslow sur la liste la lutte entre les
cartels mexicains et la cei a essayé à
l'américaine ce fait 800 pages c'est
génial voilà c'est je recommande que les
trois derniers romans qui ont marqué et
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
préconisations
je pense qu'il faut il croire
moi j'y crois
votez maquereau en 2002 c'est ça je vais
pas faire moi je vois très mac os en
2022 mais qui va se présenter comme ça
lui qui décide mais je pense que si je
vous dis que je pense que moment venu se
représentera à la
voilà jeu cet accord traduit une gamelle
pour écouter
ayant ces discussions le moment venu je
pense que vous vous reposez deux ans et
demi avant c'est-à-dire en 2015
toutes les pronostics qu'on peut faire
sur l'élection présidentielle sans
henry hermand m'avait annoncé la montée
des manuels maquereau ou trois ans moi
j'ai commencé avec ce énième a créé en
septembre 2015 donc je me croyais avant
les autres mais oui une personne et
faisant rarement personnes on peut pas
dire donc voilà on verra quelles sont
les conditions et c'est
non il croit je crois qu'il faut croire
en sa chance et les deux sons sont très
importants je pense que dans la vie 80%
c'est de la chance c'est dire que les
gens qui se raconte que voilà après il
faut travailler beaucoup il faut être
bon longuenée mais il faut y croire et
je pense qu'une tendance à penser
actuellement que la france ait perdu que
en fait une partie des réactions des
français parce que on pense que tout est
perdu et que vous limiter la casse je
pense que c'est je vais prendre un
exemple qui est assez jeu pardon je
raconte une anecdote
et il ya jack ma donc le patron
d'alibaba qui était l'elysée en mai
dernier moi j'étais là donc dans un truc
où il y avait pas mal de grands patrons
de la tech il a dit un truc qui m'a
beaucoup marqué il a dit
en fait c'est marrant vous les européens
vous êtes tout le temps peur la peur de
perdre votre boulot vous avez peur de
d'être remplacé par les chinois vous
avez peur qu'il y ait plus de retraite
vous avez peur
2 bla bla bla bla vous savez nous on est
dans un pays qui est moins riche que le
vôtre mais les seuls gens qui ont peur
c'est les vieilles personnes les gens
n'ayant pas peur est la seule chose dont
vous devez avoir peur c'est votre pc de
votre peur elle même et je pense que
c'est exactement ça c'est une phrase de
roswell there is nothing nothing to fear
of the fear itself c'est à dire que je
pense que la france porte un message et
porte une voix dans le monde je suis
insurgés pensent de ce que on a quelque
chose à faire qu'on peut le faire qu'on
a
les cerveaux pour le faire et l'énergie
pour le faire il faut croire en nous il
partit d'une partie sera de la chance il
faut quand nous c'est vrai au niveau
collectif c'est vrai au niveau
individuel mois de ma vie j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance beaucoup de chance si
j'avais pas eu de chance je serai pas là
pour raconter n'importe quoi si elle
changerait pas là mais un moment faut
croire en soi cédric ou merci beaucoup
[Musique]